[Applause]
[Music]
contagious this world entrepreneurs we
get no value to hate it how they run
homie look what I become
[Music]
walking around it wasn't a big deal but
all right so welcome part two with Jank
uh in the house from The Young Turks and
last time we did this it was a great
conversation a lot of people didn't know
what direction it was going to go we had
a fantastic conversation and uh a lot of
times you'll say hey we'd love to have
you back he's like yeah it's kind of
like one of the things you're supposed
to say no we wanted you back and uh
we're glad to have you here today I know
you got a couple announcements you want
to be making you said that on Twitter so
we'll see what that's all about oh yeah
but how you doing how you been uh great
uh thanks for having me back I love the
conversation last time too I'm looking
forward to this very cool and this is
the season right we're getting close to
the playoffs right this this is like
your world season's coming up yep uh
this is when uh you know if you follow
like the NBA you know Stephen A Smith
Inside the NBA the closer he gets to the
playoffs are going to see what's going
to make it who's going to do this it
gets intense this is like season season
for this show
um so did you did you find hello uh by
the way I got a video I want to show you
I think you saw it already
uh we'll be releasing it here today we
showed one of the clips of it two weeks
ago with Dave Smith uh and it was a
small segment of it where he talked
about uh uh you know how you know
weapons of not weapons it was you know
the uh uh folks who want to make money
off War what do they call the the
military admission conflicts he kind of
commented on that with Ukraine Russia
today there's a video we'll show that
has to do with you know Putin what they
want to do with Putin what his
interpretation of it was Four Star
General and we'll show that to the
public uh Devin Archer yesterday you
know showing up and doing what he did
and there's a bunch of people from both
sides one side is saying it's nothing
the other side's saying it's this is it
everybody in that family's got to go to
jail the kids got to go to jail the
wives got to go to jail everyone we got
to go to jail and then uh we got couple
stories here about uh uh from uh uh
Daily Mail we'll talk about Elon Musk
refutes the the logo at the top that he
put the X with the lights which
obviously anybody that lives around that
area it's a very um comforting way to go
to sleep when you have that much light
it's like a tanning bed type of a model
light uh climate change obsession is a
real mental disorder according to Wall
Street Journal we're curious to know
what you think about it Bill Barr said
he will jump off a bridge if Trump is a
2024 nominee the only question
everyone's got to ask is which bridge is
it because it's looking like that's the
direction it's going and then doj forced
to clarify it does not want to jail hunt
her business partner then we got JFK's
director Oliver Stone he fears world war
three could start Biden suggests
Republicans will impeach him because if
inflation is down Rand Paul announces
official criminal referral fauci kovit
is a lie
chance of the centers winning 2024
nominations fading that's Daily Mail I
want to get your thoughts on him uh
we're having we're uh paying people to
hate America musk and Ramos one had the
conversation I want to know what you
think about ramaswani and how RFK is
doing and then zelinski's warns war is
returning to Russia after Moscow drone
attacks and maybe a couple other things
but musk not wanted to give Starling to
Ukraine and who knows maybe we may touch
a couple uh trans videos just to get a
little reaction but every week have you
seen Oppenheimer yet I have yeah what'd
you think about it I loved it I thought
it might be a top 20 movie of all time
get out of here yeah I loved it tell me
why uh it's riveting uh it's
action-packed and it delivers an
important message too I mean look I
think the most important message
actually comes at the beginning uh that
we won the war because of diversity uh
the Nazis hated the Jews and they drove
out all the Jews who uh and it turned
out almost all the top physicists in the
world at that time were Jewish Albert
Einstein hello yeah and Oppenheimer and
Niels Bohr and it goes on and on I don't
forget if it was Bora bore's wife uh but
most of the the physicists at the time
were Jewish so they came to America and
so we developed a bomb and they didn't
if if he wasn't so anti-semitic the
Nazis might have won the war and so
thank God that that they were like
racist in all the ironic ways Etc it was
obviously awful led to Awful results but
it shows you that America's vision is
correct all of you who believe in
Freedom and hope and democracy come here
will work together we'll be diverse and
we'll get to the right results right I
mean they the thing that they developed
is of course
fearsome and and not a great thing for
the world overall the fact that we have
these nuclear weapons but they were
gonna get developed no matter what and
thank God America did it before Russia
or Germany so I just thought it was an
incredibly powerful do you think it was
long or do you think it was like did you
ever feel like it was a little too long
or did you were you okay with the three
hours no I loved it I loved it every
minute of it I didn't get bored at all
and by the way it's just an amazing
weekend for movies because I I also saw
barbie and I also love Barbie okay I
haven't seen Barbie I saw Mission
Impossible I went to watch Oppenheimer
Friday night an hour and 10 minutes
until I fell asleep not because the
movie I had a long day my day started
early so I said Babe let's go home we
went home the next day I took my son 11
year old and my nine-year-old my
nine-year-old gave it a two my 11 year
old gave it a nine wow hiko was like
this was an amazing yeah I mean listen
if you're somebody especially with
what's going on today by the way uh
there's a lot it's a very interesting
timing with this movie coming out one
with the camera conversation about
unions I want to kind of talk to you
about unions a little bit because you
know what's going on with UPS the union
30 million minimum wage you know for
full-time you know 49 bucks et cetera et
cetera and then part-time is 21 and then
also what's going on with the union
strike in Hollywood sag all of that
stuff and then also the way movie ended
you know when they're looking at it just
says you realize what we invented right
yeah yeah and it's scary it's scary
right that clip that shows like what if
the you know the nuclear bomb takes over
the entire planet and you know something
like that happens
um I walked out of the movie This 85
year old man is sitting in front of me
I'm saying 85 I didn't ask his age I'm
just assuming he's 85. yeah my dad's 81
he walked like my dad plus four more
years
and right afterwards excuse me sir so
what'd you think about the movie you
know from your perspective
this is so scary
I said tell me why it's so scary he says
because we could be there
I said what do you mean we could be
there he says because we're playing with
fire right now yeah you know Ukraine and
Russia and all this stuff this could
actually we're acting like world war
three is not possible it could happen at
any time if we push the envelope a
little bit too far so open-ended
question for you do you think the proxy
war America is playing this ain't the
first time we've done this you know
we've done it for a long time many other
countries do it all the time China does
it Russia does it you know it's a thing
you're instigating between two countries
yes one you're representing NATO because
you're part of NATO two you're
anti-russia three there's some
controversy with Ukraine barisma all
that other stuff that's going in there
do you think we are playing with fire
that it could lead to possible world war
three or you're like nah it's less than
one percent chance
well I would never say that it's less
than one percent chance I'm always
worried and I think it's uh complicated
so first of all honestly I walked out of
that movie thinking oh my God Trump
cannot be president again we cannot have
a deeply unstable guy as president and
and part of the reason was the scene
with Truman and so I don't want to give
too much of the movie away but Truman is
kind of flippant in the movie at least
about using the bomb and I thought man
if you have a guy who's not a serious
person in that office and is kind of
flipping about using the bomb and next
you know the other side launches and
then we're in a world of trouble like we
trouble we cannot recover from now in
terms of the Ukraine war I I have a
nuanced opinion on it and we have had
that opinion for a long time on Young
Turks and it's number one we push too
much in the beginning like we push NATO
too close to Russia and we don't need it
if they had pushed their alliances next
to us we would have flipped out and we
know that for a fact because when the
Soviets moved anything into Q Cuba we
nearly went to World War III over it
right so they got forget Mexico they
were in Cuba and we almost launched
right so we should not have been pushing
that close into Russia that is a
legitimate Russian interest uh outside
of Vladimir Putin okay now having said
that uh we backed away at the end and
said Ukraine's not going to be part of
NATO and I thought that was going to do
it but it turns out no Putin was always
going to invade and so like Dick Cheney
and George Bush were always going to
invade Iraq Putin was always going to
invade Russia Ukraine and since he was
gonna it looks like he proved
definitively that he was always going to
do that that to me says the real danger
is Putin and so I'm really worried about
putting him in a corner where he thinks
I got no way out but to use some weapons
that I shouldn't use and so now having
said that you in my opinion you can't
just leave the ukrainians to die because
this madman invaded them and and took
over some portion of their territory Etc
so I think it I believe in helping the
Ukraine but I don't believe in pushing
NATO into Ukraine uh now post-war of
course is a tougher ask when the
ukrainians say well
I mean these guys invaded us right so we
got as as good a reason to be in NATO as
anyone but that's also a pretty good
reason not to have them in NATO to be
honest and it's that so that puts it as
a very difficult question not an easy
one I gotta follow-up for you on that so
you know how I'll tell you my concern
like conservatives were like capitals
I'm a capitalist but I'm all day long
I'm very comfortable saying it you're a
socialist we'll have the conversation
what democratic socialists you'll call
yourself or no as I explained in my book
uh just coming I call myself a
democratic capitalist yeah I remember as
a democratic Capital yeah so for me I'm
a pure capitalist is what I am right I'm
a capitalist you know become more
conservative leanings how I want to
raise my kids family certain things I'm
not for totally fine I love this course
I love conversation these are my
favorite conversations about the guys
that I can sit there and talk to because
you can uh point out my leaks and my
argument I'll kind of point on my licks
and yours and you can defend yours I can
defend mine yep but when Biden was
getting elected what were conservatives
so worried about oh my God he's gonna
raise taxes capital gain is going to go
to this and he's going to do this and
he's going to do its end of the world if
this guy gets elected nothing happened
with taxes just to be fair I just want
to say that 100 100 so meaning that fear
Republicans had that it was going to
happen quickly within 2020 2021 2022
hasn't happened yet now one could say
well Biden didn't deliver on his
promises fine but all I'm saying is the
Boogeyman didn't happen to those who
voted against him perfect
now let's flip it on the other side the
fear a lot of times Democrats will say
is oh there's no way after watching
Oppenheimer after seeing what happened
with you know Truman after seeing this
and you're not the only person that's in
this a lot of people feel the same way
because the the movie people were split
this is why Trump can't be this is why
they don't know I can't believe Biden
it's great that's what you want to hear
you may say Trump was going to start a
war he's the guy that actually didn't
he's the guy that calmed a lot of things
down ISIS you know you know North Korea
North Korea meeting with these guys I
don't like it I don't like this I don't
like that nothing happened with Russia
and Ukraine and now he's going out there
saying if I get elected within 24 hours
you know he's famous for saying lines
like that within 24 hours I would end
this and here's how I would do it so the
proof isn't a pudding to say
those who thought this guy's going to be
a you know a button away from nuclear
war they were wrong it didn't happen and
those who said Biden's going to increase
taxes to socialist levels they were also
wrong so do you feel now even though
you're seeing this with you know Ukraine
Russia there is little less credibility
in the fear of trump starting a war
since he did in the first four years he
was in so first of all that's a fair
argument because you already had Trump
as president so it's totally a fair
point now having said that no I don't
feel that much more comfortable
um so and the reason is in 2016 I didn't
know quite how crazy Donald Trump was I
knew I thought he was not very
intelligent not very a good businessman
not very competent uh not a very good
person but I didn't know he was
full-blown nuts now I know he's
full-blown nuts now having said that
Trump's a complicated character when it
comes to war but like he claims that
he's anti-war but on the other hand he
greatly increased drone strikes so
that's not a very anti-militaristic
angle but you could say like Tulsi
gabbard does hey I think the drones
prevent more War I I don't agree with
that but I understand that uh but he
killed suleimani the top general for the
Iranians that could have easily
triggered a war with Iran or got super
lucky that Iran did not counter-attack
if they had counter-attacked now we're
in the middle of a disastrous war in the
Middle East Iran is four times larger
than Iraq and he played with fire he
played with fire in moving the embassy
in Israel he played with fire over and
over again now at the same time look he
didn't start any new Wars and credit
where credit is due and that and people
look our show drives people crazy
because we just keep telling things that
are true not based on whether it's
Republican or Democrat right and so you
give I give Joe Biden a ton of credit
for withdrawing from Afghanistan
mainstream media was like oh that was
terrible the way he was true it's always
terrible when we with like the the
process by which we were literally
responsible on the way of the withdrawn
no I totally totally disagree I know I'm
the only one in media do you mind taking
a second and just saying why you
disagree yeah because so first of all I
give Trump credit for starting the
withdrawal from Afghanistan and I give
Biden a lot of credit for finishing the
withdrawal from Afghanistan and what
people do and this is a giant phenomenon
in media that you that everyone should
be aware of needles and Haystacks like
whenever somebody wants to criticize
someone else they go and they look for
the needle in a haystack if the guy is
relatively innocent right and then they
go look at the needle look at it look at
the needle don't look at the haystack
right both sides all sides now there's
28 different sides they all no questions
right so in that case they're like oh my
God look at the people that died in the
withdrawal why because mainstream media
corporate media overall did not want the
withdrawal they love war and so they
didn't want Biden to withdraw anybody
and if it was Trump the same exact thing
would have happened because the
withdrawal it was already planned for a
long long time and even so they screwed
up parts of it because they're human and
that's the military that's the United
States military the best military in the
world and they still screwed up parts of
it right and if Trump had done it people
would have said oh I can't believe Trump
is withdrawing in all the wrong ways
they're not criticizing Biden and Trump
were withdrawing uh they're criticizing
them for the way that they withdrawed
but I think they're full of crap I think
they actually didn't want to withdraw in
the first place so I actually think
Biden has done pretty decent job on
foreign policy but Jang yeah I'm with
you though it was time to get out of
Afghanistan 20 years it was forever but
I mean a lot of people can argue left to
right the withdrawal in itself was a
freaking disaster of course we left
hundreds of billions of weapons and
tanks and it's 83 billion whatever okay
100 billion almost yeah
you know it could have been done better
is all I'm saying and not even a needle
Haystack thing no okay it was a mess
look listen but I'm glad we got out it's
my point I made that case two years ago
this was a mess but I'm glad we're out
the last things I'll say out of this
yeah I'm not I criticize buying maybe
more than any show any host in America
right so having said that look I get it
could it have been done better of course
of course it could have been done better
right but but
part of the problem is that the Pentagon
wants to leave 83 billion dollars of
equipment behind because they love get
funneling as much of our money in pork
barrel spending and the military
industrial complex as they can uh into
defense contractors
one point right there you're saying hey
we left that is going to like the
ex-girlfriend hey I left my earring at
your house I gotta come back
now that you say the way you do I think
we're all on the same page we could have
left better we should have left we're
glad he followed through on Trump
wanting to leave that's a place of unity
where we can be on the same page when
you leave is it always ugly yes did we
leave that weapon behind we shouldn't
have left it behind but we know the
military industrial complex you know
makes more money if you kind of leave it
behind because we got to make more [__]
to sell it to you now so uh everybody
kind of goes some happening 100 minus
the populace who's sitting there saying
what the f what was this all about right
but totally fine and by the way Ukraine
same thing we need to get them weapons
but there's a ton of scary yeah okay so
let's go there so let's go let's go
there I appreciate you for for doing
that Rob so General McChrystal four-star
general this is not a regular General
this is a guy that was under Obama I had
him on the podcast I think seven years
ago so very good conversation he wrote a
book on leadership phenomenal book that
he wrote on leadership one of our
sources she sent us this and you know
this is a conversation that's being had
it's a follow-up from the other
conversation the other one was more
about military industrial complex this
is about what's most likely going to be
happening we'll put I'm going to get
your reaction on this go ahead Rob
it's time to talk about but I am worried
about this
respect of this war
has attacked with a new confused or
whatever in Ukraine yeah
I think is that a real risk
with the answers from you never know
with Russia you never know with Putin so
the answer is I could never say no
there's no obvious better solution in
Russia I think Putin ought to go but
there's nobody that I'm aware of
standing on the wings
I just think that where we are now to
sort of take it back
we are saying that Russia must fail
that to me means regime change in Russia
so our policy is unofficially regime
change in Russia and that's scary when
you think of Al Putin music because I
think it's essential to him exactly I
mean if you've used it that way and
that's how I connect the dots
um I'm not sure we got there
intentionally or unintentionally but if
we are angling for replacement of his
regime what will he do to survive in
power yeah that's yeah just here is uh
so what's your reaction to that first
one of our contributors got him fired
originally uh Michael Hastings was a
contributor for Young Turks then he
wrote the piece of Rolling Stone about
my crystal and that's what got him fired
uh okay in terms of his actual
commentary I think he's just speculating
so I'm worried about a couple of things
I think he's right that uh Russia might
use tactical nukes if they're put in a
corner I think he's right that if you if
your policy was regime changed that
would be a disastrous policy uh but I
think he's speculating that we're going
for regime change I hope not I haven't
seen any indication of that and I think
that that would be a terrible policy and
I think that's why they haven't said
anything along the lines of regime
change do you think
um
for example your paranoid guy you're
you're from Turkey right I'm from Iran
yeah and I'm Armenian yeah so we're not
supposed to get along we have civil
conversations no problem we're good to
go right but you know they say the top
uh five most angriest people in the
world you know who are in the top five
have you seen this list or no statista I
haven't but if you ask Twitter
if it has Twitter they say me but
types of people countries look at this
the top five angriest this is going to
be classic if you actually pull up the
right list check this out right there
look at this zoom in number one is
Lebanon number two is turkey look who's
number three all right so we've got a
turkin and Armenian sitting right next
to each other right now right totally
okay well if you ain't as bad I took in
an Armenian sitting next to each other
every day on The Young Turks because my
Co-op houses are right yeah so this is
yeah I know Anna yeah so so this is
great so but but the point being like
we're naturally paranoid you're paranoid
I think you come across as a paranoid
guy I'm a very paranoid guy living the
life I've lived I don't trust everything
easily so I'm kind of like that kind of
was a scary comment damage for example
when they say things like the following
when Klaus Schwab says or Bill Gates in
2015 or you know Jeb Boyce said in the
2015 campaign or whatever 2015 or was it
2020 I think it was 2015 2016 when he
says we have to be ready we need a
leader that knows how to handle a
national crisis that could happen such
as a pandemic I'm like wait what it's a
pandemic and you know we are not a
pandemic for many many years and Bill
Gates only about pandemic we have to be
ready for a pandemic okay
so when they say stuff like that to me
sometimes I go like got it I kind of
know what you're saying like when a
person comes and tries to sell you
something and I'm an insurance person
I've been in insurance for my entire
life so if they come and say hey uh Jake
what are you gonna do if you die how's
your family going to be taken care of so
part of me that's like
are you and my wife talking is there
something that's going on why you want
to sell me a five million dollar policy
but the natural instinct is a little bit
paranoid so when I hear him say if
they're saying this you best believe
they're saying it because they're
creating the boogeyman the you know
hegelian dialectic whatever you want to
call it to put the fear in before we say
no we told you this is a very
problematic man we have to get him to be
replaced do you think there's any
indication of a Future Truth telling us
that you know in their own political way
because they're more pros at propaganda
than you and I are uh we got to get rid
of this guy the world's a safer place if
we get rid of Putin and then all of a
sudden they get rid of them so one
you're saying no because you already
addressed that no I don't think that's
really what's going on but two
let's say they do let's say they succeed
let's say in the next six 12 months 18
months they get what they want assuming
that's what they want what happens next
if Putin gets replaced look I despise
Putin and I've made no uh you know bones
about that I've been very clear I've
been so clear Russia Today asked me for
interviews uh right after I criticized
Putin and they're like oh well we just
like to interview I'm like oh that's
interesting why today what would you
like to talk about they're like the
Armenian Genocide I was like huh
interesting interesting so Putin is
apparently perfectly aware of how much I
despise him but I think the idea of
getting rid of him is absolutely
disastrous so if I was advising the
president I would say how in the world
do you know who would replace them right
so maybe it's a much better guy maybe
it's a much worse guy yeah the guy from
the Wagner group yeah
that's just that's a huge possibility
and that guy is much more of a warlord
and he's a private mercenary and very
dangerous Etc so as much as it goes in
right yeah yeah that's right and as much
is I think Putin has done great damage
to the world I don't think it's our
business to go interfere with how
they're selecting their leaders look I
think a lot of our our homelands have
terrible leaders I don't like erdogan
and turkey I think Netanyahu and Israel
is a disaster I can go on and on right
but that doesn't mean we got to go
meddling their business and tell them
what to do right and so hey get out of
Ukraine perfectly legitimate but the
minute you step an inch into Russia or
Russian politics it is a disaster do not
do that get the hell out of there as
soon as you can so what what success
have we had the United States in any
sort of regime in the last 50 never like
never name one that regime change has
worked out well Gaddafi and Libya all
right Iraq Saddam Hussein the list goes
on I mean can you think of one yeah well
look so yeah it's Saddam was a terrible
guy Gaddafi was a terrible guy but did
we replace them with folks who are
better I mean how many people did we
kill to get there uh near you know
hundreds of thousands of innocent Iraqi
civilians killed let alone 50 000
Americans maimed over there uh and and
killed and we go on and on our treasure
our blood so the whole country's sick of
these wars the only people who want the
wars are the establishment and why does
the establishment want it because
lobbyists win everything and so and and
we have several different lobbies that
are pushed for these kind of Wars so
you've got the obvious you've got the
oil guys that are constantly pushing for
war in the Middle East right and in case
of Russia you've got not only those guys
but you've got
um the guys who say hey I rather sell
natural gas to Europe than than Russia
and if you think that's not a
consideration uh you're incredibly naive
money makes the world go around so if
you want to know what people are going
to do look at where the money is and
you'll know exactly where they're going
arms dealers military industrial complex
and by the way Bankers who speculate
speculate on it there's there's a ton of
people modernity Traders yeah and again
you were saying like so you more fearful
if Trump Trump comes in about nuclear
war and stuff obviously I think we're
closer to it now with what's happening
in Russia and Ukraine uh and my I worked
at a nuclear missile Base in Montana
when people are like I don't I don't
trust this guy because he has his finger
on the button it's a complete fallacy to
launch a nuke the process of what it
takes to actually launch something is
absurd like it's insane people think
that somebody's sitting there like this
that's all Bs do you think we would be
where we are with Ukraine or Russian the
whole situation right now if Trump was
still in or do you think regardless it
was going to happen no matter what I I
think that Trump would have led Putin
take as much of Ukraine as he wanted to
be honest and so you can make two
arguments about that you can say hey you
know what if you just let Russia take
Ukraine there's less war boom they took
it it's over right and what do we care
if they take Ukraine so I think that's a
callous argument but that's an argument
you could make that's not not an
argument I agree with but uh but in
terms of the whole idea that I'm going
to settle Russia and Ukraine in a day
come on stop being a jackass and even
mag doesn't believe that I mean it's
absurd right you see what zielinsky had
to say about that yeah and so I want to
say one more thing about your question
yeah look uh North Korea developed eight
nukes while Trump was President yep he's
so he's all Bluster he's all talk he has
no action all Kim Jong-un had to do was
send him one letter saying that hey man
hey bro I really like you right and he
crossed the DMZ and he actually stepped
into yeah North Korea and then he came
out and said that he that they're
sending love letters to one another and
that they're in love what kind of loser
says that about by the way a communist
dictator if Obama or Biden had said he
was in love with a communist dictator
Mega would have ripped their heads off
Trump says that the excuse everything he
does so I'm not I don't think he's tough
you know I don't and I'm not sure that
he's gonna award War I mean did the
eight nukes North Korea develop make us
closer or further away from War I don't
know if you would attack them earlier
they would have obliterated Seoul South
Korea let alone Japan so these are
different questions and people keep
saying they're easy when they're not
easy let's stay there let's stay there
this is good so let's stay on this topic
in regards to Trump Love sometimes you
know I've been in sales for a long time
and I see how some people sell some
people sell through flattery some people
get their ways through making you you
know there's different ways of selling
some people sell through consultative
closing if I were you I would do this
some sell through hey you're so
beautiful you're so this you're so bad
you're so smart like that that instantly
worked but but yeah
[Laughter]
but the point is like I watch how
different presidents said like you know
when Obama went to Cuba the baseball
game and they're sitting there like oh
my God I can't believe something all
right so Obama also has his stuff with
who he said that but we can go with
everybody that's done this okay Trump
has his own way of selling that he's
been selling in New York whether it
sells or not he you know we were at
peace for four years we haven't talked
Isis since 2014 2015. so that is the
part with them how he's going to fix
Ukraine Russia in 24 hours everybody
wants to know how he's going to do it
he's presented it the weather's going to
work out or not most people don't
believe it's going to take 24 hours so
I'm going to be there with you on that
but there's still one part when you
think about
this whole situation with you know what
they're doing okay so Putin says Russia
put nuclear bombs in Belarus as warning
to the West this was a couple weeks ago
this was a month ago when he said that
even recently he's like hey you're
playing with fire now at this point
Putin's given a nuclear threat how many
times I don't know how many times I'm
going to say more than five times so if
you're gonna do it either do it or you
don't do it right so it's either you're
you're over bluffing your hand now and
no one knows you got pocket aces you
follow it you don't have Ace King and
you just kind of like acting like you
got a card you got a 210 or you have a
decent hand but you don't want to go all
in because you want me to think you have
Aces we got pocket tens let's just say
right okay fair cool
um
but should we sit there and not take the
threat of the possibility that it could
happen and us keep feeding Ukraine and
giving them more and more and more
ammunition playing more and more and
more proxy war
and you know if you you brought up I
think you brought a Cuban Cuban Missile
Crisis earlier and by the way there was
a part of it that turkey and Italy were
involved yeah that's right where turkey
saved America yeah essentially where he
said hey you guys gotta like your
missiles you got to give them up or you
guys can't use them and then boom it
kind of came back run what if JFK didn't
do that what if that wasn't the strategy
came up years later we didn't find out
about it at the beginning because it was
kind of low-key yeah can you pull that
up turkey Italy is this the one
yeah that's the one sealing the deal
with Italy and turkey 60 years ago
during April 1963 the U.S Air Force took
steps to implement the final stage of
the secret U.S Soviet deal that helped
resolve the Cuban Missile Crisis with
the dismantling of the Jupiter missiles
deployed in Italy and turkey so
that some people could say this is going
to save the world it's going to save the
day world war three this was like a big
deal that happened okay so good for JFK
for kind of taking that route flip that
on Biden
I don't know man I mean you know your
your
you're feeding the machine
non-stop to get Putin where you're
cornering the guy either do something
about it and get the guy to fall or
you're publicly saying here's who we're
going to keep empowering and then the
argument then comes back remember John
Bolton is that his name John Bolton John
Bolton the war guy right that hates
Trump yeah yeah you know he's like yeah
that's okay so what happened what
happened what Republicans being the
party that was the party of military
industrial complex and hey you know the
movie Vice and look at the rumsfield and
look at the chain look at these guys
look how much money is being made beyond
all they want to do is war war
Republicans want to war every day dude
it's like right now the Democrats are
the ones that won war on Trump the one
that everybody hates from the left
that's the guy that didn't want war he
says all I want is I want people to stop
dying yeah I want people to stop dying
right so how did the Democrats all of a
sudden become the military-industrial
complex party yeah I can tell you
exactly we have followed the money
everything is in the money so Trump is
not actually anti-war he just makes
money in a different way than the
Democrats make it okay so for example
Trump has made money from the Russians
the Saudis Etc in his private life right
so when they asked him about the Saudis
he said look they buy my apartments for
40 million dollars what do you want me
to do not like them right but no one
died okay no no I know I'm just telling
people's motivation there's a ways to
make money without killing people yeah
and so in that case that's actually to
Trump's benefit because he's saying look
I make money from the Russians his son
say all the time we got all our money
from the Russians so in that case yeah I
mean if you're Ukrainian you're not
happy if Trump wins yeah okay but if
you're an American who doesn't want any
piece of that war then I get where
you're coming from why did the Democrats
switch and become military and
industrial complex guys because everyone
takes donor money and the Democrats now
take more donor not more money than the
Republicans do their problems are even
more corrupt but they do take more money
than Trump because Trump is having
trouble getting money from donors it's
not that he wouldn't it's just that he
can't right so he doesn't feel as
indebted to them whereas Biden feels
indebted and Hillary Clinton and all of
them do to every company you can imagine
including defense contractors so when
defense contractors say JUMP he says how
high so I'll give you an example from
the Ukraine war so they did that
accounting trick I don't know if you
guys caught it about a month ago or so
but they say oh it turns out we can
spend twice as much money in in Ukraine
uh and give them twice as many weapons
and the accounting trick was oh we're
going to pretend that these uh things
that we're selling them are new but
they're not selling them new weapons
they're selling them old weapons right
so they it's an accounting gimmick why
did they do that yeah ostensibly to help
Ukraine more in this fight against
Russia but also because then the defense
contractors would make twice as much
money and all of a sudden you saw every
corporate Republican which is nearly 100
of them and every corporate Democrat
which is about 80 percent of them all
jump on up and go yes oh okay accounting
error of course all the Democrats cry
about oh defense is spending too much
Etc or not all Democrats some of them do
and then what do they do rubber stamp
rubber stamp rubber stamp yes the
defense is awesome give them everything
they want give them 100 billion more
than they want the Pentagon gets audited
they can never pass an audit they waste
half our money 400 billion dollars in
the toilet to the most corrupt people on
Earth every single year while the
Democrats the Republicans and corporate
media both mainstream media and Fox News
celebrate they go out with pom-poms yay
war war defense contractors are the best
so yes the number one problem that the
Democratic party has and I talk about it
in my book is that
they are totally captured Now by
lobbyists and by corporate cash and so
unfortunately that's also the problem
the Republicans have and so and part of
the reason and this is what
establishment media does not understand
about Donald Trump
yes I think I think Hillary Clinton said
two correct things in our life one of
them was the deplorable line that
everybody hates no that's totally true
in my opinion half the Republican base
is deplorable and and I think they are
racist bigot sexist Etc we could talk
half half easily half okay but the other
half 40 million people in America
absolutely you believe that a hundred
percent we could debate it okay but hold
on let me get to the other 40 million
okay the other 36 million or so that
voted for Trump no they're just angry
The Establishment is screwing them and
they don't know how they're getting
screwed dates that's exactly what
Charlie Kirk says right and that's
scorned and and and they hate mainstream
media and they're right because
mainstream media is a factory of Lies so
they'll say oh the status quo is great
for who yay the billionaires who run
those companies the millionaires who are
on air yes for you guys everything's
hunky-dory but it's not great for when
wages I didn't go up for 45 straight
years now because of inflation they
ironically went up a little bit but for
45 years straight wages did not go up
okay we have no Health Universal Health
Care in this country when every other
developed World developed country in the
world has it we have no paid family
leave we send moms back to the assembly
lines and coal mines the day after they
deliver so we have corporate rule in
America and chapter five is about the
Matrix and that's mainstream media that
lulls you back to sleep corporate power
is awesome corporate rule is great the
lobbyists are innocent the politicians
oh my God they're such sweethearts
they're having ideological differences
and they're having debates no they're
not they're getting checks and then
doing exactly as they are told and
that's true of 99 of the Republican
party and yes 80 percent of the
democratic party at least stopped the
way you just said it was so funny so so
99 of Republican party 80 the Democratic
party okay uh can you pull up the the
chart that just came up this one right
here total spending of presidential
campaign financing United States they
change a law I think in 2019 2020 that
allowed corporate corporations to just
open up their checkbooks I'm sure you're
familiar with this look at the kind of
money we raise for presidential
campaigns from Carter 197 million to
Reagan 228 million to Reagan again 380
to uh Bush senior 346 to Clinton 478 to
Clinton again 612 then it's Bush 891
then it's Obama I think it's what's that
1.769 billion 1.4 billion again Obama
1.529 million Hillary Trump boom
4 billion dollars whatever they could to
get rid of trump they spend all the
money in the world to get rid of this
guy they they figured out ways to say
dude if we can outspend that guy because
you know you we can be controlled so
this is the part where for me where we
agree and where we disagree this is the
part like I had Ari Fleischer here you
know who Ari Fleischer and I'm like you
know a couple of the decisions you guys
mean when you listen to the CI and these
I'm like
why wouldn't you double verify this you
know this is a big decision you're
making to do this to do that well I
don't know man we could have done this
and we could have done that and we had
Paul manafort here I'm like dude labian
why won't it's the dirtiest thing out
there and he's like well I totally get
it but you know him and Roger Stone
started the lobbying firm I don't know
what in one of the most powerful Lobby
firms that they had together nine thirty
years ago 40 years ago he said what do
you have the other guy's going to do it
what are you going to do sit on the
sidelines okay valid point but I like
both sides not to do it right however
when you look at it now and you see the
kind of money that's being spent on the
left for them to push their agendas over
you set aside this uh Lobby stuff out
you set aside corporations putting money
in to who they buy like you know the
joke about Koch brothers well you know
he wakes up and says what do I get for
my birthday which president right now
it's more the left that's doing that you
got the sorosis you got the Larry Fink
and BlackRock without their ESG score
and you know State Street and Vanguard
and that thing's becoming a reality
where it's no longer about democrat or
republican it's truly becoming more
about the establishment folks and the
anti-establishment folks 100 and if
we're talking anti-establishment Jake
you have to agree on this bro you have
to agree on this I know it's going to be
tough for you to agree on this but if
you don't give me everything you got
what I say right now you can't say Trump
is an establishment candidate no uh but
I can't say he's corrupt so there's a
huge difference okay fair go for it okay
so Trump is not establishment The
Establishment hates him you're totally
right about that okay and so which for
guys like us we like that don't we yeah
but then you have to see okay why do
they hate him right and so number one
he's unstable so businesses can't be
controlled and that's also true though
okay well no he can't be controlled
because he's so unstable and unhinged
which is a strength though in a way it
is an edge you have against your enemy
because your if the enemy feels they
can't control you
dude we have to eliminate you if we
can't control you well okay now let's
talk about that though okay so now why
do I still say he's super corrupt and by
the way that stat those stats you showed
are in my book okay and I explain why
once the Supreme Court uh activist
judges on the Supreme Court change the
rules they basically allowed for bribery
okay that's insane they legalized
bribery I outline it perfectly clearly
and there was a a guy from the Chamber
of Commerce Lewis Powell who said we
could just buy the Supreme we if we get
on the Supreme Court we could buy the
whole country corporations just can
outspend everyone right and so and they
did it Nixon said boom you're on the
Supreme Court and they did it in baloney
they did in Buckley Valeo they legalized
bribery now Trump had trouble getting
money from normal corporate interests
and I agree that's normally a good thing
right so what did he do he had to go
make up the money so he went and talked
to Sheldon Adelson so Sheldon Adelson is
actually before he passed away in 2021
largest political donor in history he
gave 100 million dollars to Trump twice
to him and his tax in 2016 and 2020.
what did he get in return he got charges
corruption charges in China dismissed
against they'll be fair he's like the
Sorrows of the right he was like the
Sorrows of the right that's right casino
Tycoon sure pro-israel yeah he got
everything he's the guy who got the
embassy moved he's the guy who
repatriating taxes from abroad because
most of his money is in Macau China
because that's where most of his casinos
are you know business and he got that
tax that knocked down to eight percent
so from 35 to 8 he made billions off of
trump and on top of getting rid of the
corruption charges and the tax cuts and
everything just as a little tchotchke
Trump threw in Miriam Adelson getting
the presidential medal of freedom his
wife his wife are you kidding me so
Trump could easily be bought dude Obama
got a Nobel Prize a month after being a
president just for what he was I know
but that isn't about corruption that was
just them being silly right okay so so
my point is for a Dei score Trump is
perfectly corrupt and and can can be
bought it's just that who's buying him
is the question I don't I don't know so
you read the portion about Adelson in my
book sure there's no question he did
everything that angel said ask him and
by the way I say to the readers are you
sure you wouldn't if somebody funneled
100 million dollars to you and then 200
million dollars to you I would I'm sorry
right look I've given up a lot of money
to do the right thing in different
portions of my career but I haven't seen
a lot of other people do that so my
point is that money is intoxicating it
corrupts trump it corrupts Biden and and
by the way here I'll go further now bro
patch back on that when you're done all
right one last thing about it to me
though look let's look at the flip side
mainstream media will tell you oh the
Republicans Mitch McConnell when he
takes a billion dollars from corporate
interests he's obviously corrupt and
look at it he's working for the
corporations Etc right but wait a minute
Nancy Pelosi also took a billion dollars
and almost all from the same donors
so why aren't you calling her corrupt
and everyone in mainstream media says no
Nancy Pelosi is an angel and she's a
master legislator so when Mitch
McConnell takes a billion dollars he's a
crook but when Nancy Pelosi takes a
billion dollars she's an angel no
they're all Crooks that's why we have
Feinstein drooling I'm sorry but it's a
reality in the Senate Mitch McConnell
freezes he's like they're all 90 years
old why because corporations know they
get a great return on investment from
those people no question we're on the
same page there just so you know we're
but but here's here's how I uh uh gauge
who can be bright and who can't be
bribed okay so most of the time you know
like uh this this Leon black story I
don't know if you saw the Leon black
story with Epstein where you know he
paid Epstein 158 million dollars for
Consulting fees and estate plan yeah
he's over a five-year period and sure
well you made 158 million dollars and
then story comes out about a 16 year old
girl who was autistic and you know so
Jesus yeah this story came out it's
pretty wild so you hear stories like
this and you're like okay he was bad
then then you watch this video from and
you'll see where I'm going with this can
you pull up the video clip of Neil
deGrasse Tyson I don't know if you have
it or not I almost I almost don't I'll
play this clip here in a minute because
I don't want to confuse the two clips
I'll come back to it where you know the
point is being some people flip their
positions suddenly where you're like why
you would have never said that why are
you saying it now what happened to you
at least with you where you're at some
people are saying what are you doing bro
why are you not like making a couple
adjustments you know like well you're
like no this is all I'm gonna talk about
and great so you're not controlled
people may not agree with you but you
don't come across as a guy that's
controlled right they don't have to like
you but you don't come across as a guy
now some will say well you took money
from sorrows in the past they'll say all
I'm saying to you is what they'll say
that that's happened all that stuff but
to me you're unhinged you're not
controlled and they don't like people
like you and I totally get you could
make a couple adjustments to increase
your business Affairs but that's to you
you've chosen to play the right that
you're playing
when I watch a trump and I watch some of
these guys I'm like okay that guy you
can win him over just introduce them to
a couple girls he's good easiest way to
win guys over right yes typically guys
that don't get a lot of play and they're
not good with words they're not good
with the ladies
you know hey go do XYZ to him and he's
going to fall for it at a bar boom hey
here's the clip we got from the room
with you guess what can happen to
anybody by the way right okay
so girls is one of the ways of doing it
attention is another way of doing it
Fame is another way of doing it you know
money is another way of doing it guess
what Trump has that at all he said all
the girls one too many sometimes okay
some that he was single some that he
wasn't single he's had all the money
he's been to all the parties he's got
all the letters from all the most
powerful people in the world telling
them how much they love him Alec Baldwin
no one ever treated me like this Oprah
Winfrey you know that book he wrote
about all the letters that others wrote
for him that now they hate him Chuck
Schumer used to love me he used to love
me when this this that you know that
whole talk that he gave me and he's
right about that part yeah so but the
point is he's had the girls he's had the
fame he's at the properties he's been to
the parties
he's had the money
how the hell are you gonna like does he
want to be if he's worth 2.5 billion
right now he's not let's just say his
word well he's not he's a total loser
he's almost bankrupt wow okay so you can
say that and that's fine but you can't
say he's a loser but but if you say he's
bankrupt you can say that can be your
opinion but but the last 60 years or the
last 50 years proves you wrong okay it
doesn't it proves me 15 years Apprentice
was number one how the hell are you that
entertaining to be number one for 15
years right you know uh financially real
estate properties when you think about a
real estate name brand you think about
one name you don't think about 50
different names you think about a guy
that's been able to Brand himself you
think about Trump now are you going to
buy Trump steak probably not but you're
going to buy neither did anybody else
but the point is he's had great
victories he's got kids that are doing
well for themselves he's got a daughter
that you know has Biden yeah
that's it that was a different angle you
took but but where I'm going with this
is that's the part where I feel they
can't stand the guy because they cannot
control them so for me when I see
you know what's going on with them
wanting to get rid of this guy and
you're like look the big donors don't
want to give them money look how much
money he got no he can't raise any money
nobody wants to give him any money and
look at this stuff yeah but the people
that are raising money are the people
that are not being trusted because
they're part of the establishment left
or right A lot of people are saying this
is why guys like RFK are getting some
momentum that's why guys like Vivek are
getting some momentum because vivex got
his own money rfk's coming out doing
some Grassroots stuff so what are your
thoughts on this with Trump yeah so
first of all was Trump look the guy's
got a insatiable greed so I don't buy
that oh he's had enough he's never had
enough okay number two he's a
natural-born loser he's lost at
everything except two things obviously
he won the presidency in 2016 yeah he
lost a popular vote but then Democrats
cry about then they should the Electoral
College is terrible it's a disaster but
he won the Electoral College he won it
right so you give him that for sure and
he's great at marketing just blah blah
blah Trump trump
and Democrats don't get it there's such
Knuckleheads they're like oh we haven't
an accomplishment we should whisper
about it on NPR no you should scream at
the top of your lungs like Trump does
but having said that bankrupt six times
got clowned in 2020 and he's been crying
about it ever since like a little
spoiled brat and it had to have his dad
get him into the schools that he got
into he hides his grades from high
school and college because he's a loser
he's a spoiled little baby he blew 413
million dollars from his dad blew it all
then he got 400 million dollars from
Apprentice why was that successful
because the producers I know the
producers on that show they had to treat
him like a baby hey baby come here baby
say this the same producers have done
shows that flopped yeah you know but
they've also the same producers who did
other number one so hard to keep a
number one hit show for okay but but if
you want to say Trump is entertaining I
don't I don't disagree with you yeah
that's what I'm saying he's pretty good
at marketing right and he says these
terrible things but they're but people
laugh right and I get it and you know
his giant strength that people don't
talk about and and no one in my tree
media acknowledges this he doesn't look
fake I think he's a con man and he's
been a con man his whole life but he
looks authentic because he doesn't go
off a prompter and you think well that's
a real guy he's saying crazy crap that
nobody else would say and all the other
politicians look like actors they
they're robots they come out like Pete
budage came out from a factory everybody
knows that right Gavin Newsom but also
DeSantis and McConnell they're all
robots they come and I will do this I
have been told by my donors this is
great policy right and so he has a
feeling so authenticity but if you look
at his records like you say great in
real estate he's awful in real estate in
Atlantic City he built three casinos
everybody said you're going to
cannibalize it you [__] your own
business and you know one of his top
assistants says he just likes his name
and lights so he'd like to see Trump
trump in Atlantic City and he bankrupted
all three because he sucks at business
you think you're good in business yes
you think you're good yes shank yes
seriously 100 okay so when's your
birthday by the way what month's your
birthday March 30 21st years okay your
price your Pisces Aries beginning oh you
made it to Aries yes interesting my
dad's in there is I get along with Aries
okay so uh he's on April 10th your mom
so you barely are an Aries though by one
day beginning of uh the interviews
so so okay bro when you say that you
know for me I feel like if there's
anybody that would be like a pro-trump
kind of confusing way would be you okay
I know this is like this guy's lost his
mind you have no clue who the f I am are
you crazy there's no way
because
um in business you know do you have a
perfect record with business no do I
have a perfect record with business no
nobody does yeah nobody does but you
know has Trump taken it to certain
levels that his dad didn't take it yeah
that's not easy to do his dad wasn't as
famous as this guy got it's a very hard
work to do that there's a lot of kids
that are spoiled kids from a rich father
who don't do [__] with the money and
they become crack addicts and they
become drug addicts and they hire
prostitutes all the time and they go try
to sell their laptops at different
places and they you know I'm not saying
about anybody specific but this happens
every once in a while right there is
there's there's stories like that and
you hear us like oh okay this guy's
gonna make it this guy's not going to
make it so there is something about him
one can say John F Kennedy became a
president because of his father Joseph
Kennedy because okay fine and Joseph
Kennedy became successful because his
dad had all this money from okay fine
okay there's some of it that's got to go
to the credit of the individual perfect
so if I listen to you and I didn't know
who you were okay and I just came to
America and I've heard about this Trump
guy and I've heard about the Biden guy
and I'm listening to you I would say
that guy is angry at Trump for what
reason he's either envious of trump he's
angry with them because he sounds
personal he doesn't sound like he's
being reasonable he sounds he's being
personal when he's attacking Trump and I
I think he loses credibility a little
bit for taking the angle that he does
because you're coming from a place of
saying this guy got this much money and
he became Rich because of this and he's
a loser he's a this to the guy who was
on Oprah Winfrey 1988.
and Oprah Winfrey says so hey uh you
sound like somebody that's gonna you've
seen this you sound like somebody that's
going to run for office one day no no
well do you have any plans no but if I
ever did I would win who the hell says
that that's like a Babe Ruth call you
know when you say I want to hit the homo
you point the finger and you hit it his
book crushed it his show crushed it he
crushed it in New York going up against
all these other guys he's done good with
women he's done good with his kids he
became a president I don't know love him
or hate him I don't have a relationship
with them so there is not like a I'm
defending this guy I'm doing it we're in
Florida because of the Santas we came
here because then all of a sudden the
Santas I'm watching him mark it I'm like
dude you're not even out there doing
your part marketing finally he's getting
to it and now everybody's asking a
question that they shouldn't be asking
you which is what why are you so down on
the polls can you make a comeback you
should have never allowed these people
to ask that question if you would have
played offense earlier but when you see
a winner
and complicated individual a
misunderstood individual
I don't know how many people you're
going to put on the list as Trump in in
the history of America by the way
whether you love this guy or hate this
guy it's kind of tough to you know uh
demonize the guy's resume and I know you
like to do this but it's kind of tough
to do it not remotely tough you think so
Pat look I'm giving you nuanced answers
I'm telling you that he's
anti-establishment in some ways so
that's part of his appeal I'm telling
you he's good at marketing and almost
everything you're saying is he's good at
marketing he was good on TV he was good
at marketing his book he went on Oprah
it's marketing marketing Mark no you
said he wanted two things and what I did
is I showed his resume that's more than
two things it's a bunch of different
things that he wanted that was my
defense to you saying he only wanted two
things not the market Pat imagine
imagine if your dad gave you 413 million
dollars which we don't we don't know
that's the number but you're saying yeah
says this was 400 the New York Times
also said science New York Times
has also lied about me I understand that
okay but but his dad was enormously
wealthy there's no question about
enormous yeah and which he lost 4 13 by
today's standards or what was it back
then what was the actual question
no no no no no no no way it's it's look
I forget I think it's by today's
standards but I'm not positive it could
have been fourth but it's not 14 to 413
that's not how inflation works so but
Pat if they gave it to you you'd
probably be worth 4 billion by now I
don't know okay
if you have kids Jake do you have kids
yes what are you talking about bro let
me let me unpack this for you so one of
the hardest things to do is to be the
pastor's kid are you are you kidding me
like the pastor's kid is like so you
gotta be a virgin till you get married
I'm gonna go freaking smoke weed then
I'm so sick and tired it's pressure when
are you gonna be this no I'm not bro I
just I remember we're at a church we're
going to the church the pastor's son you
ready for this this is a pastor loved by
so many people
his son gets arrested across the street
from the church with a crew of players
taking stuff from Best Buy and the
pastor is going to come on Sunday and
preach in front of 20 000 members so the
point I'm trying to make to you is
nobody wants to be Michael Jordan's kids
nobody wants to be Brady's kid the level
of pressure and scrutiny of wanting to
do that trust me I understand the level
of a you know uh influence and
additional cards and stuff that you can
get but we did it we did a a research on
a generational wealth I got kids and I'm
trying to see how do I set it up for my
kids to get my wealth without them being
spoiled okay so it's something that's
important to me I kind of want to figure
out I'm in a community couple families
do it right so I said let me go ahead
and study this to see how to do it right
Vanderbilts do you know how long the
wealth lasted this guy was the richest
man in the world giving money back to
the country you know how much how many
generations money lasts two generations
it's usually it's always two the only
General the only Welch that lasted seven
generations the Medici Medici lasted
seven generations is the only one every
other one is two three rockefeller's
still on four right now they're not even
on five six seven so so the notion when
you're saying like if you you would have
had that start bro a lot of people you
give them money they become spoiled
little brats I had a guy I interviewed
who lives in Seattle you know what his
job was he managed the Templeton family
16 grandkids you know what his job was
his job was he was the guy dealing with
billionaire families and the reason why
Seattle you know why Seattle Amazon
Microsoft all those guys all these
there's all these billionaires and guys
that are worth 100 million that no one
knows who they are he's worth 28 million
148 million 300 million yes sir they're
kids drug addicts he says my biggest job
with these guys was to make sure they
didn't do drugs they didn't do out there
so but you know what the biggest problem
with me was he says what's that they
typically came to me too late they came
to me too late that I couldn't do
anything about it dude this guy's never
drank alcohol he's never done drugs he
doesn't do that I mean that kind of
stuff to come from that amount of
opportunity to screw up because that's
not easy to do six bankruptcies I mean
just you run when you no look people
make mistakes in business if you're not
making mistakes you're not really a
businessman like there's no question I
get it right and I'd cut them a lot of
I'd cut any business person a lot of
slack for you got a bankruptcy you got
two bankruptcies it happens brother six
he's never had a successful business
Trump Stakes Trump water Trump
casinos you can't name a successful
business he bought a airplane uh company
instant he put gold seats in a in an
economy uh Airline and immediately went
bankrupt he's terrible at business but
look if you say it's personal well
number one it isn't because I'm giving
you Nuance on both sides okay but having
said that
look it got personal when he lost the
election in 2020 and said ah screw it
I'm going to try a coup I'm gonna do
these fake electors scheme I'm gonna try
to Rob America of its democracy just so
I can stay in power screw that guy and
if any of you are voting for that guy
who's totally Un-American who betrayed
this country you're nuts and he won't
ever leave office he's a wannabe
dictator he always Praises dictators
whether it's g in China whether it's Kim
Jong-un in North Korea Putin he's always
saying oh they get all the Applause when
they walk in no one is allowed to
disagree with them and then freedom
freedom my ass he hates Freedom he wants
to take away everyone's Freedom so that
all the power goes to him okay so no Pat
look you see I'm not laughing at you
it's entertaining what you're saying and
and it's 100 true I can see okay so let
me ask you a different question who do
you trust more him or Biden I don't
trust either one of them it's not about
Trump okay so so who do you who do you
see more if your choices are the two
guys right now you're gonna sit this one
out oh no way I'm gonna vote Biden okay
so because I want another election I
don't want I don't if you put Trump back
in charge there's at least a 50 chance
we're never gonna have another so let me
ask you this other question to the
people who when Hillary lost you've seen
that clip on Hillary lost it's the it's
one of the greatest uh Bill Burr said it
best when he was on Conan O'Brien he
says look man forget about the the
Olympics Russia U.S forget about you
know the Home Run forget about this he
says dude this guy beat Hillary Clinton
it's like the people lost their minds
right what did Hillary Clinton do for
four years you know what she did she
went around campaigning around what they
stole the election they stole the
election they stole the election they
and we whatever before before she was
doing it with all that [__] no but
they didn't say that he physically stole
election there's a giant giant
difference saying oh boohoo which he did
of like oh my the Russians interfered in
election which by the way they did but
not enough to make the difference okay
but that's just crying after your loss
whereas Donald Trump's knows it had a
scheme of fake electors to do a goddamn
Coupe Hillary did not concealed Hillary
and she did actually conceive wait wait
hold on she conceded well here's my
question Jank so let's say you are Trump
you're you're you you legitimately win
the election
don't use the word legitimate time out
time out you won in 2016. you find out
all these years later with the dorm
report and all that [__] that not only
did Hitler help set up lawyers the
dossier everything how can you blame
somebody for not trusting the FBI or the
elect everything in 2000 questions
yeah I wouldn't trust anybody okay so
look when he asked for a recount I said
hell yeah when he asked her a hand
recount I said hell yeah my progressives
have been asking to verify elections for
decades now right but when uh some
Bernie supporters back in 2016 said oh
no Hillary stole the election from
Bernie in the primaries I said look when
you're talking about how they set up the
debates how they funneled uh money from
the donors through the state uh
Democratic parties that's true okay but
if you're talking about evidence of
rigged elections you have to come with
freaking evidence and our side didn't so
I said no I don't care how angry you get
at me she Hillary Clinton did not steal
the votes in those in those elections in
the primary in 2016. so when you get to
Trump did if he says Hey I want to
recount great but they did they
recounted three times they did hand
recounts then they went to court 60
times and guys this is definitive he
couldn't present one piece of evidence
he had 60 shots at it you know why he
because there is no evidence there is no
evidence and he knows it he made it up
from day one he's a giant liar he's
always been a pathological liar and he
came here
oh I think they stole they made up seven
million votes Hugo Chavez they blamed
the Kraken all these insane donkeys or
mules or whatever the hell get out of
here hey all of Maga show me one piece
of evidence in court not BS oh I said it
on TV there's no account now all you
ever do is lie on TV all the politicians
lie on TV go to court show that the
evidence until then shut up and stop
trying to steal elections and stop
hating America America is about
elections is about democracy so so by
the way you know I will say this to you
if you could uh uh I will say this to
you so you're right when it comes down
to uh if you think the other person is
guilty show the proof and go through it
that's the whole thing with innocent
until proven guilty totally get it
abroad mainstream media ran for three
and a half years that Trump Russia all
that stuff I'm not saying you I'm saying
mainstream media you ran against them
three and a half years every day this
guy thought Russia got him elected I
mean people that we know smart guys but
brother mainstream media hates
progressives they've destroyed our
movement I'm not sure what am I I'm
saying oh we won the election but I said
to you I said in Notting not you I said
not you I said mainstream media but my
point is Pat you got to play the playing
field that's true for me that's true for
Trump sure right so yes mainstream media
hates them yes they did proper
propaganda I guess about three and a
half years but that's the playing field
right they have the edge listen
Republicans if they want to have that go
buy some Republican go buy some media
companies and compete directly yeah musk
is buying Twitter great go at it play
your game if you're gonna do what you're
gonna Murdoch influences elections more
than anyone else murdoches right now
more at a whole different place he's no
longer yeah you know that bro he's not
but where I was going to this the
following okay so the part for me that
got confusing was to follow okay
do you remember during colvid uh I had a
lady named Judy Mike of it's on who used
to work with uh oh
fauci in 1980s what the aides think oh
my God it was like boom two million
views taken down short clip strike
strike what
okay let's interview this other guy boom
strike strike okay all right boom
strikes they took like 40 of our videos
down during covet and we kept doing the
interviews and we were not like well
this is 5G remember to hold 5G thing
like that fizzled out very quickly
everybody thought it was a 5G but there
was a community that was like well this
is what's going on here's what they're
doing that's what they're doing okay
cool
you know we're like god let's kind of
take a look at to see what's going on
Election claims yeah this is what they
did you know the drop and pump okay yeah
election fraud has been going on for a
long time okay this ain't anything new
it was something known for Democrats
that would do a lot with John F Kennedy
do we all this stuff and it's been going
on for many many years great okay
they're doing that but if you put up any
Clips disputing it guess what you were
getting strikes and they were taking
those videos down
then two three months ago YouTube comes
out and saying moving forward we're no
longer taking those videos down they can
stay up okay
why would YouTube do that why would
YouTube not allow it for two and a half
years and all of a sudden YouTube can
you pull up that clip on YouTube change
your guidelines on Election claim or
whatever like now moving forward we're
not going to take you down and we're
changing our guidelines for it so I'm
not saying one or the other
but did YouTube behind closed doors are
they worried about a Twitter files
coming out are they worried about yeah
YouTube changes policy to allow false
claims about past U.S presidential
elections YouTube will stop removing
content that falsely claims the 2020
election or other past U.S presidential
elections were marred by widespread
fraud errors or glitches the platform
announced Friday this is what AP News
less than two months ago it's exactly
two months ago you know it was when they
put it up why would they do that all
right I have a good theory I'm curious I
want to hear your theory what they would
do yeah because now every Republican
believes it let's say like eight out of
10 Republicans believe it so what are
they gonna do ban every Republican so I
think they got to a point where they're
like we give up uh every right winger
believes this nonsense that's totally
made up so we can't ban all the right
Wingers so we just got to let him say it
how much of it is well you know these
guys on Rumble are kind of
it's got no steam at all Steven
Crowder's career is dead everybody who's
on rumble's dead Stephen Crowder's
career is dead of course he went to
rumble three people watch there that's a
terrible mistake he should have taken
the daily wire deal I forget politics
right daily wire offers him 50 million
dollars he could have stayed on YouTube
he would have been relevant and had more
money it was a disastrous decision by
him look I'm happy to be wrong if it
turns out Rumble does great going
forward I'll come back and say I was
wrong but I I'm telling you guys on
Rumble right now obviously profession
fit is on there sneakers on there not
that they're in the politics two or
three people who are getting views but
on YouTube the whole world is getting
views right YouTube has taken over the
planet and that's part of why they're
doing this because they're like what are
we going to do not allow any right
Wingers on YouTube but if you guys say
they're a little worried about
competition Fair no problem I'm sure
they consider that their business so we
got two theories so far your theory is 8
out of 10 Republicans believe the
election was fraught so that's like hey
let's not lose the Republican Republic
Republicans buy shoes as well look
that's kind of like your angle where
you're taking you're saying Rumbles
giving him competition maybe that's it
maybe let's add Twitter in it because
Twitter's eventually going to be doing
video so I think actually Twitter is a
bigger fear to YouTube than Rumble is
probably no matter how much they trash
Twitter I think Twitter's gonna
eventually figure it out I don't think
elon's a guy that gives up easily it's
called X now let's let's go I don't I
don't know how to say I'm gonna ex uh go
read my ex I just exceeded something
it's kind of weird right so but we'll
adjust to it yeah yeah we'll react we'll
adjust to but to me that was kind of
weird when they did that and and you
know my other theory was maybe
you know the whole like I said earlier
Twitter files information came out how
many people on the fauci side were you
know embarrassed on what's going on even
Rand Paul came out here and announced
his official criminal referral fauci
kovit is a lie uh page 11 I'll read this
story here Rob if you want to pull it up
uh uh
Senator Rand Paul made an official
criminal referral to the department
Justice accusing Dr Anthony foucher
perjury uh uh perjury during this
testimony about covid-19 and funding
gain of function research in China's
Wuhan lab Paul called for an
investigation into fauci's uh knowledge
of dangerous virus research fauci faced
criticism after release emails revealed
he knew about gain of function research
in one lab despite denying it during
previous testimony the government uh
accountability office confirmed
Institute of virology and Wuhan
University received NIH funding for
Coronavirus research the debate over
covid-19 origin continues with some
officials suspecting a lab leak Theory
due to the Wuhan Labs location and
research history while other others
support a natural spillover event uh uh
from animals so
are they afraid that maybe a YouTube
files is going to come out and they're
going to show behind closed doors
communication with fauci about not
allowing those types of videos to be
shown I don't know are they uh Twitter
your YouTube file is going to come out
emails saying hey you can't let them
show these clips about
you know what they're doing with the
election and what happened to it and
those videos with this mules and all
this stuff you can't let that those guys
got to be taken down this is creating
too much momentum maybe could it be that
uh they uh were afraid for maybe
additional stuff to come out with
communication with Biden I don't know
like I remember when they changed one of
my favorite things about YouTube I don't
know if you like this one I loved it
when you could give a thumbs up or
thumbs down yeah you know I love the
thumbs down thing because I'm like we
would do a video I'm like damn I thought
this was a good video they hated this
video you know the ratios was so bad
with thumbs down to thumbs up
Biden's videos I don't know if you
remember this okay dude when he was
campaigning it was like 28 000 likes 600
000 dislikes yeah like every videos if
you like it was bad to dislike racial
was astronomical it got so bad and out
of nowhere during election they said uh
due to mental and anxiety for kids we're
gonna get rid of thumbs down yeah
so feelings over logic you know some of
this stuff may be for me where YouTube
is sitting there saying Twitter's
becoming real competition we the last
thing we want is the government to start
investigating some of our emails on what
we did and what if this stuff leaked
yeah that could be a theory we're going
to talk about cheating the FBI working
with the White House and or just do to
censor stories and don't put out you
know the how many was it eighty percent
of Voters or 75 were like if we knew
about the hunter Biden laptop and what
by everything that's coming out right
now we want to voted for him that's if
we're going to talk about interference
and cheating the guy that's sitting in
right now and I know you're not you're
not a fan nope I don't think anybody at
this point is but that is hands down
cheating with with the Department of
Justice and now it's like man nobody
nobody really cares but I mean look you
can make the same argument for if James
Comey hadn't come out with the Anthony
Weiner laptop Hillary Clinton wins right
and so did they rig the election in
favor of Donald Trump the first time
around so there's a ton of factors that
go into an election in terms of YouTube
uh I think they mainly took it away for
like political correctness slash mental
health reasons Etc when I'm but I don't
mean it for Biden I mean it like kids
these days are very upset if anyone does
a thumb who cares they need that no
because they care about kids because
that's a huge huge part of Their
audience but in terms of Biden of course
he gets 600 000 dislikes why two reasons
number one he's a fake politician and
people don't like fake politicians on
YouTube and number two because the
Republican Troll Army is gigantic they
like the Democratic trolls are barely
exist although now on the rad radical
left or some right but but the right
wing is all trolls so they're of course
but those are look Pat I know YouTube
and it's a giant business those are
minuscule concerns for them now if you
want to get to fauci that's an
interesting topic okay so I'm a huge
believer in vaccines I think those
vaccines saved millions of lives I think
they were great I think the scientists
in the world are correct Bob on Facebook
is incorrect now having said that we do
Nuance truth matters right it's not
about ideology so was it a lab leak
probably okay and I said that well over
two years ago because first thing they
come out and they say okay we got a a
covert outbreak here uh right next to
the Wuhan lab on virology and I'm like
yeah well yeah it doesn't take a rocket
scientist to figure this out right yeah
or a virologist right and then they said
no all the scientists have weighed in
and it wasn't a lab leak I go okay I
believe a scientist so I said I guess it
wasn't it although it looks but I guess
it wasn't and then they put out a
statement like around middle of 2021
early 2021 they're like uh we were kind
of lying about that and yeah and the
scientists don't agree I was like oh
that's it I'm out it's definitely like I
don't I can't say it's definitely a
loudly because I don't have the evidence
right but logically it is very likely to
be elaborated remember the uh the um Jon
Stewart going on Stephen Colbert yeah
remember that whole reaction and this
was when the lat like have you even
brought up the lab League it was like
you're a conspiracy theorist it's like
why everything you just said was
absolutely correct because the the leak
came right in Wuhan right next to the
Wuhan virologist Institute of lab leaks
you know like what okay but Jon Stewart
went on there this one and he basically
was like
essentially stating exactly what you're
saying is like but you want me to
believe that a bat made out with the
Pangolin and then that's it it's like it
just makes sense and by the way when
they put out things like that and it
turns out it was like four government
scientists when they put out statements
like that they do great damage to
science because then they lose
credibility
you we need people to believe them it's
really important and so they're still
playing around with some things around
around political correctness and so it
drives me crazy you know you have to
follow actual science right and not for
leave ideology and how do you feel drink
about like uh Pat who's that guy that um
RFK was like I'll they'll debate the guy
but Peter Hotel Peter's and he's like
well like how do you feel about them
like literally like like an RFK I don't
know how you feel about them I'm
interested to see but if you're a
scientist what are you scared about to
sit there and talk with a guy that's not
a scientist but he's dedicated his
entire life to this this world why
wouldn't you want to show the world like
hey I'll debunk whatever this RFK
character is going to talk about why why
wouldn't they do that I know the
specific answer to that because I know
RFK Jr from a long time ago because he
was you know a significant uh left
Winger for a long time Environmental
Lawyer yeah and he was actually a really
good lawyer and and cares a lot about
the environment so another nuanced guy
okay so he asked me to find scientists
to debate him on vaccines well before
covet because he's always been a gas
Factor got you right and I went and
tried because I thought we like exchange
of ideas we allow for disagreements on
tyt right so uh and I asked a bunch of
scientists to do it and they wouldn't do
it why at the time there wasn't as much
skepticism about vaccines and they're
like so if I go on it seems like a 50 50
debate when it's not a 50 50 debate it's
not me it's every scientist in the world
versus RFK Jr but if they're watching
that debate they can't get a sense of
that that's point one and point two I'm
not great at debating I'm great at
science right and so if this guy beats
me in a debate because he does some
rhetorical tricks or something I I've
set signs back instead of forward that's
why they didn't want to do it nowadays I
think there's a better argument to do it
find a great you know debater Among The
Sciences you got to find one or two
right and have them say over and over
again the thing that is true 99 of the
world's doctors and 99 of the world's
scientists believe in these vaccines and
they believe in them for a reason and by
the way we're now doing the same thing
fundamentalist Muslims did when we and
and I researched this when RFK Jr asked
me about it however many years ago five
seven eight years ago right uh and like
they were doing polio vaccines in
Pakistan and they're like oh yeah the
Christians are trying to put you know
something in our blood and we don't want
it not all of Pakistan but some portions
the ones that are closer to Afghanistan
and then because they didn't get the
vaccines polio struck and then when
their kids were disabled they're like no
please
America scientists come back okay but it
was too late by that now our own
Christian fundamentalists are doing the
same thing no I don't want the vaccine
they're gonna put a chip in me dude Elon
Musk is trying to put trips in your
brain and you're okay with it but you
thought there was some 5G crap in your
in the vaccine no vaccines saved lives
there's a story out today that
hundreds of thousands more Republicans
died because they didn't take the
vaccine you're only hurting yourself we
were trying to help you but look now the
dangerous past in terms of like
spreading it to other people now it's
turned into basically a common cold so
if you don't want to take the vaccine
have that at Haas don't take it I don't
care at all because it's your business
not my business then it becomes just an
issue of Freedom then you're right but
before it was an issue of spreading it
to other people got you well I mean
you're saying that you know where you're
talking about the vaccine saved so many
lives all this other stuff you have one
of two positions to take there okay when
you say that
and this kind of works against Trump by
the way because it's his own side that
didn't take the vaccine when he says no
I'm the one that did you know warps you
know there was sped off yeah if it
wasn't for me which he's right he's the
guy that did it and sped up the process
and Pfizer announced the vaccine a week
after election actually three or four
days after election when it was finally
approved it's going to come out versus
coming out two days before they could
have announced it so we know some of
that stuff that's kind of fishy right so
you know what do you say to these
stories that's coming up athletes you
know passing out bronnie James LeBron
James the other day middle USC you know
is a myocarditis and you know the
athlete Hamlin from Buffalo Bills and
you're seeing more and more and more
videos creating that World Cup soccer
level of skepticism with the side
effects of a covet vaccine because they
only had nine months to test it out and
how do we know it was fully good and the
the you know side effects that it has
how do you respond to that now so the
science on that one is unsettled so uh
some people like there's a lot of people
making up stuff oh I got a shoulder egg
I got a baggie that's got nothing to do
with vaccines okay but now on that heart
issue uh they've changed the numbers
twice okay so they said it was a lot
more rare then they said it's a little
less rare now it's a little less rare
right now by the way that doesn't mean
that you shouldn't necessarily take the
vaccine because hey the vaccine side
effects could affect you know 10 of
people but if you don't take the vaccine
20 could die right so vaccines again it
doesn't mean you just don't take it but
but there could be an argument totally
unsettled I'm not saying this is the
case I'm saying they got to look a lot
more into it and for God's sake let them
do actual science without political
interference from either side right so
look into it more and it might make
sense that the young don't take the
vaccine I was just gonna say there's no
reason why he's 18 now so it would have
been 16 at the time let's say a 16 year
old world-class All-American athlete
like a brownie James should be even
consider taking the vaccine yeah it
makes no sense no no grandma James who's
88 years old wants to take the vaccine
go for it yeah you want to take it
obviously go for it but to be mandated
for a young healthy guy that makes no
sense I hear you on all that and I'm
just going to say one last thing about
that guys so a lot of people
misunderstand science so when I say the
science is unsettled that's because they
haven't done enough studies yet right
that doesn't mean oh they're rigging it
and they're changing the numbers no you
change the numbers there's more facts
come in right that's ultimately rfk's
entire point is it not not exactly rfk's
always been against vaccines but I've
never supported I think it's more about
it against mandating vaccines without
them being tested that's the I don't
think he's about no vaccines are all bad
he goes we need the testing yes he's not
for all yes and no I I've read the whole
book I don't know if you read his whole
book or not I've read the whole book
cover to cover very very technical book
it's not a book you read and it's like a
you know you have to be ready when you
read that book and set the phone aside
get away from the kids to be able to
read that book but you know I think you
sound reasonable right now when I'm
listening to you just to be fair with
you you sound very reasonable you took
how many boosters did you take by the
way uh probably I took three shots
overall I think oh so you took the two
shots and one booster no I took uh
Johnson to Johnson Johnson so I took one
shot in the beginning and then two
boosters okay got it fair so I haven't
taken anything by the way I'm not I
didn't take any of it in our family my
dad took everything Plus for boosters
and he is the most conservative guy in
our family so he's not a like you know
he's far on a complete uh he's an
imperialist he's a shot guy so just kind
of if you want to see where he's at our
Nanny took it uh I didn't take it my
wife didn't take it our kids didn't take
it but
when you see this thing that the biggest
concern for me with this is this report
came on New York Times reports
coronavirus that's over counted by 30 on
paragraph 17 you can find this and we
went to New York Times we found it was
like yeah you know we over countered it
maybe by about 30 percent these types of
reports that's coming out I'm not going
to debate this is not a debate I'm just
going to give my thoughts and we'll go
to the next issue the part that was a
little bit concerning with this
was again going back to
the judgmental side dude people got out
of the military before not wanting to
take the vaccine it was the force part
when you say yeah of course we don't
have enough data we get data on the
facts change and numbers I don't yeah I
agree I totally agree but allow me to
have the level of uh the option to say
can I see a little bit more into side
effects happens for me to want to take
it sure no if you don't you're fired if
you don't this if you don't this that
was the part that I think they played
their cards in a way that completely
lost the trust of the populace in a big
way where they forced it down people's
throat without being able to see what
the real consequences were but I want to
ask you about RFK since uh
Vinnie brought it up and uh um I do know
you also have two announcements to make
we got one more hour just so you know
whenever you're ready to announce that
you let us know but guys if you're
watching this you're enjoying this
podcast with Jake this is our second
time doing it some of you guys are like
well how come you haven't talked about
this how come you haven't talked about
that we talked about a lot of stuff last
time you can always go watch the last
podcast we did together but if you
enjoyed Today's Show give it a thumbs up
subscribe to the channel also we got a
live podcast Town Hall that's coming up
this Friday with Vivek ramaswani at our
other building where uh he'll be there
with myself for two hours to address
questions with the audience uh I know
the first two tier tickets have sold out
we got a couple General tickets left
text award three one uh the word podcast
to three one zero three four zero one
one three two again text award podcast
to
310-340-1132 to get the link uh to
registered for the event with vivec
that's coming up this Friday so okay RFK
we can either put them together I'll
actually put both them together and can
respond you know collectively with both
of them
RFK when I interviewed him the first
some three years ago during coven
I never thought he's gonna run like that
was never like rfk's gonna run and I
don't even know if he wanted to run I
don't know you know how some people for
years like DeSantis I feel like he's
been wanting to run his entire life
Hillary I feel like she's wanted to run
her entire life I mean Romney yeah I
feel like a lot of we can't give a list
you know who these guys are on the list
totally I don't think RFK was on that
list I don't think he cared to run you
know want to do it vivec maybe I think
Vivek is ambition is enough to think
that he thought he would be the youngest
president ever I can actually believe
that I'm 50 50 there
why do you think of vivec
that's almost passed up the scientists
okay why is vivec and RFK why are they
doing so well uh in this election why do
you think they're doing so well yeah two
totally different reasons so uh and I
pulled this and I haven't told anybody
about this poll before and I'll tell you
uh on the Democratic side there is a
great hunger for someone who is not Joe
Biden now that's a well-known fact but
we polled it and almost every anybody on
a one-to-one matchup against Biden like
you could put in Bob Smith Jim jablowski
made up names
yeah we should actually do it Ronald
Paul and put Jim Jones and don't trust
me they would yeah there's a random guy
in Wisconsin named Jim jablowski he's
like I'm running for president yo and we
did it we did that poll included I put
my new own name in I put in a bunch of
progressives all of us got 20 or higher
yeah okay you're right there's a
yearning for him not to be the president
yeah RFK is is not actually popular when
when I I talked to Marianne Williamson's
campaign but you said RFK is actually
not popular yeah so they just don't know
who he is they're not going to him
because of his anti-vaccine stance
anti-establishment stance they're going
to him because his last name is Kennedy
and they're like oh that's better than
jablowski stop guys Adam you're saying
that is true it is true you know I'm
saying his last that's not I'm not
agreeing that it's the only reason
the other Kennedy Republican on the
other side with the accents related
he could have been a comedian he's
hilarious but that's why he was elected
Pat because he sounds like uh
but he's actually not a Kennedy so uh
anyone there so and by the way can RFK
Jr and Marianne combine have about 20
points like
they're 20 of Democrats are like I'll
give to anyone not named Biden I know 80
of that is RFK in 20 of his money that's
that's true to be fair but to be fair
Kennedy's a giant name versus Marianne
and Mary has been smeared by the media
Etc right so but if you're saying is
there an anti-establishment vibe in the
Democratic party hell yes hell yes it's
larger than 20 why do you think Bernie
almost caught Hillary and by the way he
should have been the candidate he should
have been of course of course Hillary
Hillary did her due diligence with the
DNC and they screwed him that was his
chance yeah and look I said Bernie could
win back in 2013 three years before he
closed a 50-point lead right yeah and
why because there's this great hunger
for don't give me fake politicians yes
and they all they have all these stupid
mythology That No One Believes oh Joe
Biden's the boy from Scranton now he's a
boy from Washington DC yeah I mean we're
not blind we saw him in Washington
Scranton in 60 years
Scranton okay No One Believes that horse
crap like come on oh and I fought corn
popping shut up so like nobody a
lifetime Ago by the way shockingly the
core mom story turned out to be true
rules I couldn't believe it by the way
binding lies all the time in the
mainstream media covers for it big time
so yes there's a hunger here's the goat
of that area though right line would you
say you'd put them at the top as the
goat no Trump's always stop no are you
kidding me Trump
doesn't use it every every speech he
ever gave teleprompter was written by
somebody else
plagiarizing it no no but but there's a
difference between known lying and not
known lying like Trump is knowingly
lying whereas Biden had just literally
forgetful
guys don't ever I I'm I'm putting my
foot down here don't ever ever undermine
the goat of all time of lying President
Joe Biden don't ever do that again
that's an insult this is a guy that does
it in a way I never talk to myself
did you put Newsome on the list of the
of the
did uh better than the rest when we put
a laundry list together yeah but he
didn't do but what I found interesting
about it was that he didn't jump out
like it wasn't like oh Newsome's Head
and Shoulders above everyone
well it depends so everyone in the
establishment look guys I I'll be honest
with you some people thought one of my
announces was that I'm going to announce
the run for president right and I
thought about it and I'll tell you why I
thought about it uh it's because this
this voting base is super hungry for an
actual anti-establishment person who's
actually Progressive right so rfga
Junior's got issues with Progressive
Marianne's a wonderful person but she's
mainstream media has done incredible
damage to her uh and her perception of
credibility right if you give me one
strong Progressive we'd run through this
field like a hot knife through butter
and we'd run through Biden Bernie
Sanders number one problem was that he
refused to attack Biden and we all know
this I know everyone in this campaign
they've said it publicly now they had
notes for him to go attack him during a
debate and he wouldn't do it and
honestly he prioritizes friendship with
Biden over all of his voters and so I
love Bernie but that broke my heart and
so if you said to me Bernie running
again I'd say no because he's not going
to run he's not he's going to get in the
race and then tell you Biden is great no
that's that doesn't help at all right
but he gave me one strong Progressive
and we could definitely beat by and I
got so desperate I thought about myself
right why didn't you uh so look there
you'd have to run as a third party you
can't run no Democrat I'd run as a
Democrat no way I'd run as if you'd get
smoked no I wouldn't you would get smoke
no no no you would get destroyed
absolutely they would never let a guy
like I know by they would yeah they
would make you look like yeah [__] so
look I ran for congress once and I got
eviscerated by mainstream media people
say hey why did you get loose so badly
well if I had read at 5.4 percent I got
all the way up to 6.6.6 yeah
one of them was 5.4 then you went up to
six points you know why they still
didn't stop California is incompetent in
a lot of ways that the Democrats don't
acknowledge and they never stopped they
only counted 76 percent the vote if I
was Trump I would say I won okay no no
but why did I get only 6.6 because Los
Angeles Times New York Times CNN all
told people that I was anti-muslim
anti-semitic anti-black sexist you uh
into beastiality every lie in the world
and the New York Times printed it like
it was true and so what I would tell
people is if I saw that written about a
candidate I would vote against them I'm
originally Muslim I don't want to vote
against someone who's anti-muslim and
they never gave me the mic so they never
gave me an opportunity to respond and if
you don't have an opportunity to respond
and mainstream media smears you you're
done you have no chance at all
why would it be different in the
presidential because and I'll tell this
to any Progressive who's thinking of
running and who's got any kind of
Courage okay
look guys the presidential level is
totally different there's all sorts of
press they CA they almost can't deny you
press here I am on this show I can go on
almost any right wing show I can go
almost on any online media show and so
could any strong Progressive you can go
on oan you can go on Newsmax eventually
you'll get on the Fox News look at what
vivex doing vivec was nobody nobody
nobody like let's be honest I'm 10 000
times more famous than vivec yeah before
he started right now yeah but not now
why because Rebecca's using media you
don't in the past mainstream media had a
monopoly and and during 2016 they still
had that Monopoly and so that's why the
Bernie run was miraculous miraculous and
the Press shut them out completely in
2015 as he's doing a historic run ABC
spent seven seconds talking about him in
Primetime news seven seconds they spent
more like all of the networks combined
spent like four times the amount of time
talking about Joe Biden who didn't run
in 2016 than they did about Bernie
Sanders who closed 50-point lead so the
mainstream media is the most biased they
and look they're tied with Fox News
they're all horrible but you give me a
strong Progressive you let me do
strategy for them and we will manage
that was a sister aggressive give me two
or three there's look this is the game
that everybody plays right so the minute
I name it a name everybody goes oh no
way it's a progressive real way oh they
have no credibility Etc so look I know
she lost two races right but Nina Turner
it and and those two races would be used
against her she lost two Congressional
races right who is that Senator Nina
Turner she's a [__] talker yeah rip Tina
Turner though the real one who's now she
is a Nina okay yeah I'm familiar with
her yeah Nina Turner was the chairman of
uh uh one of the Chairman's uh you think
she has a chance to be the president
United States oh hell yeah dude okay so
I know but that's what everybody says no
you're no no no answers no you're 100
wrong okay so you're buying into
mainstream media and I'll tell you why I
know
the president of the United States right
there God damn right if she ran Jack
okay relaxed so no hold on hold on hold
on y'all no no but this is
exactly what I predicted ahead of time
right here a minute ago okay the minute
I name any progressor you go oh no I
haven't heard of them no mainstream
media assistant oh no way no way hey she
doesn't look right I mean like you don't
even know anything
first of all just so you know I had no
clue what she looked like because the
only face I know is Twitter and the
videos there I go based on what she said
the stuff she says is super extreme to
you no it's not I'm just telling you
from my side I'm watching what some of
the stuff that she says she sounds
extreme but go ahead and say why you
said she would have a shot she's
anti-establishment okay so if she was on
this show and maybe you should get her
on the show she would tell you things
incredibly similar to what I'm saying so
we don't buy in to establishment
Democrats we don't buy into mainstream
media and when we don't they smear the
living hell out of us okay they smeared
me they smeared her they smeared every
Progressive I'll name but I'll name a
non-progressive to catch your attention
because I you know because we've all
been brainwashed into thinking no
Progressive could ever win right uh Jon
Stewart he'd clean Joe Biden's clock
he'd beat him in Atlanta don't disagree
right I don't disagree so just give me
someone who's kind of progressive and I
will beat Joe Biden okay
he does something that's very
interesting is he plays a joke towards
High towards his height where I don't
know if you've seen when he did it with
Bill O'Reilly and he had this thing that
brought him all the way up to be taller
than him so that in itself guess what it
does day one it's self-deprecation
nobody gives a [__] about your height
it's over with I'm with you yeah so so
so I don't yeah so so going back to that
so you know where are you going with
your announcement do you want to you
want to give it now you want to wait
till the end of the yeah no no I can
talk about look I decided not to run so
look I have two giant hurdles uh so
number one is uh you know they'll bring
up the election or you lost the
Congressional race how could you
possibly win the presidential race Etc I
can get Beyond it but it's a hurdle and
it's a pain in the ass hurt Lincoln lost
most of his races yeah so and the second
thing is I was I wasn't born in America
now in reality you can definitely run
for president Patrick good news for you
you could run for president law review
articles say absolutely Fifth Amendment
got rid of that earlier part of the
Constitution it's total mythology that
we can't run and by the way there's 45
million Americans that are naturalized
citizens it is the last allowed
discrimination where they say 15 percent
of the country is not fully American
they can't run for president when it
isn't even true the Fifth Amendment yeah
I'll give you a sense of it so you know
for sure Fifth Amendment 14th Amendment
frees the slaves gives them 100 rights
they were not natural born citizens no
one disputes that when they were born as
slaves they were not natural born
citizens after the fifth and 14th
Amendment could they run for president
of course of course they could run for
president because those amendments amend
the earlier part of the Constitution and
I'm sick of every time I meet someone
and Pat this probably happens to you too
oh you're a citizen oh where were you
born oh you weren't born here haha you
can't run for president and we all think
that that's okay like I get it people
who do it they're just they're on like
they're innocent they don't mean any
harm by it right but we every one of us
Ted Lou brought came from Taiwan when he
was five years old what are we
questioning his loyalty to America are
we questioning your loyalty to America
are we questioning my loyalty to America
that's actually deeply problematic so
it's totally realizing but it would be a
giant hurdle the minute I announced
everyone in mainstream media would say
he's eliminated don't even think about
him don't even talk about him he wasn't
born in America he's not a hundred
percent American and everybody like
Bravo great discrimination we love it we
love it and nobody even notices right so
so I need someone without those two
hurdles and Nina's got the two hurdles
because she lost those two elections
right and I get it that's real politic
right but if but give me someone like
that and by the way there's Progressive
businessmen and and people don't think
about that and they have a lot of
credibility right and so and the Press
would treat them with credibility
because they're wealthy so those guys
could run there's a ton of people who
could run and who could win and look at
what vivec is doing it's so easy and
wisely successful because number one
he's actually going on media most
corporate politicians hide from media
because they're fake they're phonies
they don't want you think they're going
to come on a podcast like this and get
grilled on actual questions do you think
they're going to come on Young Turks
they did in 2016 you should see the
interviews I did with Tim Ryan Tulsi
gabbard etc those are really important
who won't do it the corporate
politicians won't you utilize the rest
of media they'll only go on mainstream
media if you utilizing all of those
names like who's corporate politicians
left and right Hillary Clinton Joe Biden
Michigan
yeah totally yeah people and by the way
to be fair to DeSantis a lot of people
on the left say he's a fascist no I
disagree with a lot of his positions
including the racial stuff the general
identity Stuff Etc but no he's not a
fascist the fascist ends democracy
there's only one fascist that's Donald
Trump Donald Trump did fake collectors
to end a democracy that's but if you
misuse the word that's and that's goes
to one of my announcements like look I'm
declaring Young Turks mainstream
Progressive and so that's kind of bold
because it's a made-up category and when
I say it people die people all over the
Internet Hate Me Right in every
different faction and they'll say oh who
is Jake euger to make up mainstream
Progressive well I'm not going to follow
that nobody's gonna follow that well I'm
planting a flag tyt's homo progressives
that's the whole network you're a
leftist your mainstream Progressive
you're a moderate Democrat no problem
everybody come to tyt okay homo
progresses but Young Young Turks the
flagship showed that Anna and I do were
mainstream Progressive because I'm sorry
but I don't agree with the leftists I
don't agree with the radical left right
so I don't agree with the establishment
and I don't agree with those guys so
we've got to have a home for us and if
you brought me a mainstream Progressive
that doesn't have some of the radical
positions you guys are worried about we
win we win we win okay but I I tried I
asked a lot of people to run and you
know the number one uh that thing that
people are worried about when I ask
progressives about running they all say
the same thing
mainstream media mainstream media will
bury us they will try to destroy our
lives in the old days they did
assassinations now they do character
assassination we saw that they did that
with your favorite guy Trump they did
that for God knows how many years right
now look he is the ultimate character
assassination guy yet yes and no so yes
definitely the character assassinated
him but he reminds me of the Jeff sucker
quote he as to why they fired him at CNN
he had the relationship internally he's
like I loaded a gun and handed it to him
and they shot me with it right Trump is
loading gun after gun here I'll break
this cool I'll break this law I'll take
the documents home and he's handing
loaded gun after loaded gun to the
people who want to assassinate his
character in the first place right and
he makes it easy you're saying what okay
yeah you're saying Kris Cuomo basically
highlighted when we interviewed Cuomo
yeah but what's your relationship with
Chris Cuomo what do you think about
Chris I like Chris and so I get heat for
liking Chris but I like Chris you know
why I like him why is that because he's
open-minded and so he actually is more a
lot more establishment Democrat than I
am we disagree on a lot of the policies
Etc and I his brother I can't stand uh
but but Chris is the only guy who ever
had progressives on his show in cable
news no one else ever has progressives
like you like you're a likable guy in
person
yeah he's enormously and check when you
say you don't like his brother what's
the oh Andrew Cuomo's the definition of
a corrupt establishment Democrat I mean
you give him any kind of money he'll do
you any favor and the real estate
interest in New York totally owned
Andrew Cuomo Andrew Cuomo uh took out
Progressive after Progressive in New
York put in he purposely reduced the
power of the democratic party uh did a
splinter group the group that he
authorized to pretend that they had to
share power with Republicans so he could
do his donors bidding like no one does
the donor's bidding better than Andrew
Cuomo that's why when Trump uh in the
beginning if you remember before Joe
Biden before anyone else
before Andrew Cuomo ran into trouble all
of the Liberals like the establishment
Democrats were like oh yeah Andrew Cuomo
Andrew Cuomo's doing so good with
Coleman yeah Andrew Coleman tricoma why
whenever you see a lot of people talking
in the Press about positively about one
guy that is almost always propaganda
like oh and here's how you know Biden
might be on his way out all of a sudden
a glowing piece in one of the uh uh I
forget if it was Vanity Fair one of the
other pieces article magazines about
Gretchen Whitmer out of nowhere the
governor of Michigan yeah and all of a
sudden she's Our Savior I'm like why do
we need saving and then you have a
newsom's all over TV you know what that
means they're getting the Cavalry ready
because by look Biden as they should
though and they should because look my
number one problem with buying isn't how
conservative he is it's minor is it just
me is it a little hot in here okay can
we crank up the AC cause I'm trying to
see if the okay go for it so now my
number two of the problem with Biden is
the that he's a corporatist he's a liar
it's all that stuff my number one
problem with him is he's gonna lose
like we're playing with fire we talked
about it with Oppenheimer so if Trump is
as bad as I think he is would I want to
run a super weak old man who doesn't
even want to campaign against him yeah a
guy whose popularity is oftentimes in
the 30s here's a giant lie of the
mainstream media only Joe Biden can beat
Donald Trump wait why first of all tons
of people can beat Donald Trump Donald
Trump's in the 30s an approval rating uh
Jim jablowski can beat Donald Trump
the only people who can't beat Donald
Trump are establishment Democrats who
are deeply unpopular because they're
fakes and they're phonies right so they
say oh Biden beat him last time he beat
him by 43 000 votes in three swing
States it doesn't matter how much he won
the popular vote by he the Electoral
College he only won by the skid of his
teeth and he was 15 points higher at
that point the Democrats are walking
into a Slaughter with their eyes wide
open and say I would rather lose to
Trump than have a progress so so let's
let's stand so number one uh two
announcements three announcements you're
not running two young Turks is now the
progressive mainstream media is what
you're calling it is that fair what I
said mainstream Progressive mainstream
Progressive I'm sorry mainstream
Progressive and three Justice is coming
uh put the link down the first book
you've ever written we'll get back we'll
get back to this at the end of it as
well just so if some people want to
order his book we're going to put the
link below so let me let me let me go
back to this on vivec and uh RFK and
then also you're not running and you
mentioned her uh Nina Turner I think
that's her name yeah and then you
mentioned uh Jon Stewart okay so and you
also said that you could run based on
the 14th Amendment but you're not born
here so they're going to go against you
but even if they do you can still run
legally oh legally you could definitely
run but your problem isn't the legal
part the problem is everyone in media is
going to say uh don't vote for him he he
can't run legally you can run not being
born here 100 percent how do you know I
can give you the law review articles
that are written about it so how come
nobody that's not born here has ran yet
but by the way tons of people have
they're all Republicans and Republicans
get different rules and they talk about
like Ted Cruz Canada John McCain George
Romney like have the Republican
candidates are born in America so you're
saying Pat can run from known
have you ever explored what he's saying
no I haven't but what I'm saying is like
if that opened it up you know how many
people love America more than some
people that are born here who would be
formidable candidates to go compete holy
moly if they knew I don't 100 know if
you're you're uh fully there if you send
me the stuff I'd love to take off
definitely yeah look at the story now
look at the first page one patriotism is
the decline only only 18 of young adults
are extreme but but I'm gonna wrap this
up and then we'll go to them we got a
few videos I want to show you because
you mentioned some things about and I
and I want to run one more thing by yeah
great but I want to go back to this
Steward side so I agree with you in the
following area I think if a rock ever
wanted to run this is the time to do it
I think if a Steward's ever going to run
this is the time to do it I think if a
uh I don't think AOC can now I think
she's going to run in four years I think
she ought to do it but I think right now
and by the way this is not saying I
would vote for them I'm just saying as a
agent of opportunity this is the season
to run you know RFK running as a
Democrat you know initially I'm like
listen if they if you don't win you got
to run as a third party apparently you
have to run as a third party from day
one to be able to run et cetera et
cetera so that's not going to favor him
a lot why do you think Stu doesn't run
it he sounds like he wants to run he
sounds like a guy that wants to be
president he sounds like he's doing all
these debates bringing people in and
destroying them on the show I think the
show with apple whatever the show is how
come he's not running because politics
is a cesspool and he's not wrong about
that so by the way uh if he got into a
crowded field then people would the
media would assume that he's not going
to win and give him plenty of good
coverage but if he got in right now the
media would have restrained him in the
beginning there would be a flash of the
pan they'd be like oh Jon Stewart's
getting in oh that's super interesting
or we're gonna have something to talk
about yes yes if you run against a
corporate Democrat the media will
destroy you look look at what they say
about him give me an example I have no
idea they'll come up with the needles
the haystack's perfectly good we all
like the Haystacks so they're gonna dig
dig until they find needles yeah for
with me they took jokes that I made 20
years ago seven years ago 13 years ago
and pretended they weren't jokes I mean
New York Times said that bestiality was
part of my platform basically are you
insane are you a lunatic that's actually
what got my vote Jake
look at the end of the clip at the end
of the clip they're talking about I go
would a horse uh say no no right yeah
and you saw that and you said pretended
it was real
by the way the dudes born Muslim his
whole family is Muslim they just they
smeared the crap out of me isn't there a
single editor so I say that not because
of me but because they will find BS
needles in Jon Stewart's life and
they'll they'll try to destroy him with
what do you think about Cuban Mark human
Mark cube is an interesting cat I know
him a little bit he's a smart guy he's
an interesting guy he's probably too
conservative for my taste but would he
be interesting in any primary yeah of
course he would what would you consider
him on the Progressive conservative
independent you know something sometimes
he says things that I agree 100 with and
sometimes he says things that infuriate
me well that's everyone yeah so and do I
know all of his policies I think he's a
part of it I think he's doing it is
intentional yeah so non-committal to
both sides but he's way more left than
he is right so look it Devil's in the
details I care about policy more than
anything else in the world so like when
Howard Schultz ran in the beginning I
was excited I was like okay it's not a
normal politician he ran Starbucks
Starbucks was a progressive company we
thought right well now we find that
Starbucks not so Progressive Howard
Schultz definitely not Progressive and
he came out and the first thing he's
like we gotta make sure there's no tax
cuts on the rich I'm like you're running
as a Democrat and that's your war chant
nah nah so so if it turns out Mark Cuban
is not at all program aggressive then
I'm not interested but if it turns out
he's anti-establishment and a little
Progressive I'll take a little
Progressive can you do me one favor
Define progressive and then at the same
time you said you weren't a fan of the
woke left make that distinction okay
great question so number one mainstream
Progressive believes in all of Bernie
Sanders economic policies So Paid Family
Leave higher minimum wage Medicare for
all end of gerrymandering end of bribery
in politics skate corporate cash
etc those are all incredibly popular
positions two-thirds of the country
wants all of that okay but you mentioned
AOC I wouldn't advise AOC to run some of
our positions are too radical left and
the world's gonna end so she she said
the world's gonna end so why even run if
the world's gonna end well that's a
different question that's about climate
change we could come back to that but
but like she like peop she went on air
on CNN we're talking about abortion 70
of the country agrees with us they
should be legal in the first two
trimesters right and she starts
referring to mothers as birthing persons
I'm like what are you doing
you know how many people want to refer
to moms as birthing persons two percent
yeah and your girl Anna caught some heat
over that yeah and so we drew the line
and said no we're not going to call moms
people with uteruses and they're like
you're doing that out of nowhere you're
attacking us no brothers and sisters if
you're going to run against Biden you're
going to run to try to win the country
over don't go to the two percent
position go to the 70 position so many
Progressive policies are sitting right
there at 70 percent run on those but she
can't help herself so she's going to run
on things like birthing person and I
mean look some on the left now believe
in abolishing prisons
I'm sorry guys I love you and I do
they're on our Network and they're good
people and they mean well but that's not
so nobody believes in that right so do
they understand the fallacy of their
argument do they truly understand how
ridiculous they sound no they don't I
mean look they had this debate on a show
with the right winger and a left-winger
Brianna Joey gray was on the left and
she's making the argument against uh
she's making the argument for abolishing
prisons and the right-wing guy who I
don't agree with normally at all he's
like yes but if I hit somebody in their
face with a brick I go to prison right
and she's like no I'm like come on what
was there what was the reason for that
because prisons are awful that's true
prisons are awful that's why we should
reform them like for example my whole
life everybody's like oh yeah you get
raped in prison I'm like why is that oh
yeah like we should fix that comes with
the sentence right do you know that
here's your jumpsuit and then some lube
best of them you know the last time I
checked the stats more men get raped
than women because of Prisons that
doesn't insane game because they they
moved away from soaps to gel yeah
so you pull up so they're not wrong that
prisons are awful and we should reform
them and and Norway is the better model
even though it drives me crazy because I
kind of like Vengeance a little bit but
Norway it brings down recidivism so much
more than we do but but they're saying
no we get rid of them and eventually we
have Kumbaya we had them on the show we
asked a thousand times and then what and
they talk about like restorative justice
oh you can do restorative justice you
can for a lot of people right that took
the wrong turn but some folks just are
born different this guy's murdered four
people what do you want to do with this
guy yeah I'm not letting him out by the
way by the way if you ask the same exact
folks on the left
hey should Trump go to prison they're
like yes wait a minute I thought we were
abolishing prisons yeah okay why is
Trump going to prison why is why color
criminal what do they say to that they
have they want Trump to go to healthcare
like they want to put him on an island
Alcatraz with Sean Connery yeah yeah and
look I don't want to make them out to be
like a huge part of the left they're
tiny percentage of the left right
we got 30 minutes left and I got a few
more stories I want to go through this
was good very helpful did you have one
other you said you had one other thing
yeah one other thing is look guys I I'm
curious what I'm genuinely super curious
what you guys think look I've kind of
given up on Congress uh I tried the
inside strategy I try to help Bernie uh
I formed Justice Democrats we've got 11
folks in Congress now but they just
won't do it they won't pass any laws
that Americans care about and by the way
the culture wars makes everybody rich
and so the right wing loves the culture
wars the left-wing loves the culture
wars the country hates the culture wars
and the country gets nothing because of
the culture wars so uh what I want to do
is ask right-wing shows left-wing shows
and every show in the middle can we
Unite on any policy because everybody
says that the country is divided
hopelessly divided I know that isn't
true we are hopelessly divided on some
issues race gender Etc but we are not
divided on economic issues so I'm maybe
this is the best show to come on ask for
this maybe this is the worst show you I
don't know you tell me but Paid Family
Leave pulls at 84 three quarters of
Republican voters say yes I want moms to
have a break after they deliver their
children okay so can we push from the
outside can the right wing and left wing
go yeah we agree on this forget
everything else we hate each other on
everything else but we agree on this
give moms a break okay give them 12
weeks off after they deliver that's Pro
mom pro-conservative pro-life right it's
also Progressive we all agree can we
push from the outside and say God damn
it you do your stupid Hunter Biden
investigations or your brilliant Hunter
Biden investigations whatever you want
but as you're doing all of that can you
just give us one bill paid family leave
moms get 12 weeks off in Estonia they
get 82 weeks off in Sweden they get 64
weeks off in Japan they get a whole year
off why because they want to encourage
it people having kids they want to
encourage families that's why three
quarters of Republicans agree now why
don't they do it if 84 of Americans want
it because they're all corporatists the
corporate Republicans and the corporate
Democrats take money from corporations
the only people in the country who don't
want moms to get 12 weeks off are
corporate interests and they bribe all
of our politicians and that's why I've
given up on the inside track but I bet
that if all the shows on the outside or
enough of them said yes Paid Family
Leave God damn it give them at least 12
weeks off right
that maybe we can get a past where's
this poll the 84 percent do you know any
poll you can look up any poll on paid
family I just typed in right now see if
you can find a robot what is the current
uh time
zero moms have to go back to the
assembly line the day after they deliver
that's something that's in America well
I didn't P I mean I'm not trying to be
funny but people the judge had a baby
with his guy exactly three months didn't
he get three months yeah you got Monroe
you know why because 24 of Americans get
paid family leave only 24 is everybody
else in the world 100 yeah okay who are
the 24 all rich people oh all Executives
all government officials Etc so yeah so
Executives get 12 weeks off that's
standard fare okay so as a company like
we give 12 weeks off but in the
beginning the standard was you give it
to the executives and we said no we're
gonna give it to everybody and people
are like whoa you're gonna give it to
everybody that's crazy because it's in
the corporate mindset that you don't do
that for the average American so average
Americans we all agree we all agree the
media is lying we don't disagree about
everything let's go do this together
let's go past paid family leave if we
breathe down there next and you guys
breathe out on their necks they're gonna
notice media controls you ask a question
what can we agree on okay uh uh let's uh
let do me a favor pull up it was 74
Republicans 83 independent 94 Democrat
this is July 2018. can you do me a favor
let's see if we can agree on this pull
up the Neil deGrasse Tyson video okay
let's see if we can agree on this so
here's a clip I want to know what you
think about the scientist what he's
saying whether you and I can agree that
this is absolutely ludicrous or you may
say no I think there's a point here go
ahead and play this clip point is
apparently the xxxy chromosomes are
insufficient
because when we wake up in the morning
we
exaggerate whatever feature we want to
portray the gender of our choice
either the one you're assigned the one
you choose to be whatever it is and so
now here so so now just to tie a bow on
this I say to you
somewhere I read
somewhere I think I read that the United
States was a land where we have the
pursuit of happiness
yes suppose no matter my chromosomes
today I feel eighty percent female 20
man I'm gonna I'm gonna put on makeup
I'm gonna do this tomorrow I might feel
80 male I'll remove the makeup and I'll
wear a muscle shirt
why do you care
what business it is it of yours
to require
that I full fulfill
inability to this gender on a spectrum
okay pause this so why do you care
before I give you mine
do you agree with what he's saying I
largely agree tell me why so
um first of all freedom I thought the
right wing was in favor of Freedom so
people want to be trans why do you care
I totally agree with that
um and so taking away rights from people
no we're all 100 Americans you shouldn't
take away any rights but if you get into
the details that's where uh some folks
on the left have attacked me as a
transphobe because I disagree on two
percent of the issues so you tell me
what your policy you're talking about
and I'll give you my answer so for
example if you like we one of one of my
favorite shows I went with my wife in
Vegas uh absent I think it was called
absence absent or whatever I don't know
if you've been to it or not have you
seen the Caesar's Palace it's great
freaking insane show but guess what it
is a lot of crazy stuff you're gonna see
we were entertained as adults we were
absolutely entertained no problem uh you
want to dress up you want to do whatever
you want to be gay after you're 18 years
old go for you want to change your sex
you want to go from having this to
cutting this Caitlyn Jenner do your
thing whatever you want to know fault
pushing that agenda onto kids and
confusing people in gaslighting that hey
XX who knows maybe XY who knows when you
start talking like that with facts
and you're a respectable scientist not
only do you sound delusional but what
you sound like is someone like Leon
black that somebody has something behind
closed doors on you that's blackmailing
you that you have to now agree with
these positions for somebody to say how
the hell did you go from being a
respected scientist to all of a sudden
saying one day I can wake up feeling
like a female one day I can wake up
feeling like a male and why do you care
no one cares the only care where I think
Democrats are losing a big part of their
base where I don't know if you saw the
stats that came out talking about senior
boys are becoming overly conservative
did you see this chart or no that just
came out yesterday or the day before Rob
do you have this or no do you want me to
text it to you type in senior boys
conservative yeah if you can this is the
hill if you can go high school boys are
trending conservative and if you go and
show the chart there's that that chart
right there if you look at that zoom out
a little bit so we can read the whole
survey okay so political identities of
12th grade boys percent identified as
liberal versus conservative from 1975 to
today
so look at Blue where it was at and now
2023 it's conservative and less liberals
this is seniors 12th grade boys okay so
maybe some of these guys are just fed up
with another like listen man I'm sick of
this PS dude this whether I identify as
a boy or as a girl leave me alone let me
figure out when I'm an adult stop
imposing this idea on me I had Anthony
Weiner on the podcast okay a week ago I
don't know how you feel about Anthony
Weiner but I had him on the podcast a
week ago
uh and it was right before Chris Cuomo
and I look at Anthony Weiner I said you
know do you know how to give a [__]
and he looks at me in a weird way like
what kind of a question is that I said
well no do you know how to says no I
said did you learn how to give one no
nobody tell why are you asking a
question like that I said because that's
what's being taught in some Public
Schools today with books with images on
how to give it and it's normal okay now
these pictures are out there these books
are out there and they put it right on
they're sold millions of copies and a
lot of parents are around the country
are fighting for it and it's in your
state which you know that's why we got
to control straight people yeah so what
where Newsome will come out and Newsome
will say stuff like you know the Banning
of the books and banning of the books
and banning of the books and parents say
listen stop playing politics
start defending facts and stop playing
politics so can we in an area of
agreement agree that maybe all this
lgbtq agenda that you have sell it after
I'm 18 years old not when I'm in third
grade can we agree on that uh no and
I'll tell you why okay so the devil's in
the details so if you say to me hey
don't let people have irreversible
surgery before 18. I agree completely
okay so check we're on that on the same
page so what Trump is about to do 50
states he said he's not going to allow
for that surgery to take place just
surgery though just surgery is where you
are okay let's see where you go let's go
for it so
um but if you say hey they're coming
after the kids that's the oldest line of
attack against gay people in the history
of the world they're coming after your
kids they're coming after your kids I
mean look at the example you give how to
give a [__] right that doesn't say
gay or straight that's why I joked and I
said oh we got to get straight people
under control right because straight
people get tons and tons of blow jobs
and that's part of the reason why they
put it in into some and it's misguided
to put it into some of those sex
education classes right does anybody go
we got to get straight people under
control look at them teaching [__]
goddamn straight people no because they
don't want to demonize straight people
they want to demonize lgbtq people
that's why they connect lgbtq people
with children now when you say hey
groomers and pedophiles Etc well
straight people do it more why aren't we
talking about straight people there are
way more straight pedophiles there are
way more straight groomers and by the
way tons of Republicans they a new one
gets revealed every single week right so
but we don't have that conversation
instead we focus like a laser beam on
the lgbtq community because honestly the
point is to spread hate against lgbtq
Community if you say to me something has
gone out of bounds okay let's have a
discussion about it right I think
surgery under 18 is out of bounds uh by
the way this is why I'm called to
transfer by some people in the radical
level yeah and because I say look there
are some certain things that are out of
bounds uh like one of the things I
disagree with I don't think I think the
leagues the professional League should
make their own decisions about about
whether they let trans people compete in
their leagues or not and they say no
people say oh with hormones dude you
give Shack all the hormones in the world
right he's going to destroy the WNBA and
people get super mad when I say that but
no one agrees with you I love you
brothers and sisters and they're part of
my network but you Shaq is go is going
to dominate you could put every hormone
in the world men's bodies are structured
differently they maintain Mass better
they have a different bone structure
these are facts so if you're talking
about biology I agree if you're talking
about targeting lgbtq people overall and
kids No I don't agree what about puberty
blockers puberty blockers is a super
tough one so right now a lot of people
say that it's it's it's okay I'm not
positive that this science has settled
but for me I would leave up to the
families and the parents to decide like
Republicans say oh you know we're really
trying to protect parent rights when we
ban these books Etc then you go okay
parent rights on hormone therapy I don't
know their kids I don't know their
situation and I and I I'm not sure I
know the science any better than the
parents do I'll let the parents make the
decision and then the right says no
goddamn parents are not allowed to make
the decision I'm going to make the
government is going to make the decision
for them I don't agree would you say
this is the number one culture war in
America right now it is and I'll tell
you why because the right wing picked it
because they think okay and they try
different things they said all right
Trump tried to ban transgender people
from the military turned out it wasn't
popular he tried to ban uh transgender
people from bathrooms and stuff and that
didn't turn out to be popular they dug
and dug and dug until they got the
transports and so-called groomers that's
when the country goes okay that's too
much and by the way one part of the
reason I'm calling ours my mainstream
progressives is because a lot of the
leftists fell right into that trap and
that's the only thing they talk about
they stop talking about Paige family
leave and higher minimum wage and all
they're talking about is we got to get
trans people into the WNBA no that's not
the biggest culture issue in America so
you're saying this is a cultural word
that Republicans brought I don't yes 100
the National Education Association Anya
is the largest Union in America they got
three plus million members they've been
around since 1850s it's a law I don't
know what the years but they've been on
for a long time now recommends that
teachers include the controversial book
genderqueer A Memoir by Maya kobabi on
summer reading lists can you go a little
lower if you look at some of the
pictures in there zoom in a little bit
more to show these pictures what they're
doing keep going keep going keep going
keep going keep going keep going keep
going keep going keep going how to give
a [__] how to do this uh keep going
11 years old 12 years old boys and boys
yeah bro that's very weird for you by
the way no that's easy for for you no no
but hang on one second for you
to ask me to be reasonable Under 12
weeks with 74 Republican for mothers 12
weeks
and to sit there and say no you're being
ludicrous with this because we shouldn't
ban bomb books like this and we should
this be available to them yet but ask us
for this now you sound like a dictator
and you don't see the most common
argument that parents are having today
okay so think about it this way you know
State of California since 1851 they've
crushed it
I lived in California 24 years minus my
three years in the Army two and a half
years in the army I lived in Granada
Hills I went to Glendale High School I'm
a class of 96.
I lived in Porter Ranch Woodland Hills
Northridge you know earthquake I was
there 94 on base it off of Van Nuys down
the street from Caesar's pizza and you
know the DMV and the earthquake was like
a minute long I mean I've been through
all of that I lived in L.A had a great
time you know did my thing and then I
joined the army
first time they lost people leaving was
a couple years ago and they continue to
loosen and they're saying this is going
to stick around till 2060. okay where
it's not going to have the kind of
growth that they're having now whether
it's going to be 20 60 I don't think
it's going to be 26 because you know
when it comes down to that things change
fairly it takes a few years to change
but they change
when you when you talk to people who are
leaving
I think most people will stay if taxes
are higher I don't think that's why
people leave you know that they'll stay
in New York they'll sound like you know
what screw the taxes but you know what
I'll make more fine right cool I'll make
more
and then you're like you know well look
what they're doing here with this it's a
liberal policies whatever
hey we're going to start teaching this
in schools no bro you just crossed the
line with me you don't get to dictate
that with my kids I'm not good with that
you're forcing down my the throat of my
kids now I have to leave now you go to
net negative which if anybody ran
against Newsom that's all they have to
talk about while you were there you're
the first governor ever where people
left your state they left you he can say
what's the fifth biggest economy in the
world that's not because of what you did
that's because of what people did prior
to you being a governor not because of
your doing because of the people that
came before you while you were here you
lost people and they went to other
places because you started to try to
indoctrinate their kids that's crossing
the line so if you say Pat let's kind of
find an equal like one of the things you
said about covet you know what now that
I'm seeing it I chose to do it but I
don't think it's this okay fine we had
like a you know area where you sounded
reasonable assign a reason great you
know hey parents this no problem by the
way just so you know I just texted both
of my HR people while you're asking me
both the companies to ask him what's our
thing because my president that I
promoted my insurance company she's a
female she's had two kids while she's
been with me for 13 years so we've gone
through the process with them we're
checking to see whether it is to see
what the produce Pro Protocols are we're
a fair company a company bought our
company you know what the conversation
was about after they bought it they said
your benefits are too rich we're gonna
have to bring it down a little bit
before the end of the year so no problem
our benefits have always been above what
others offer no problem our minimum wage
is 15 bucks an hour we don't have an
issue with it that's always been the
case for many years
so but in this area brother if you look
at this area and say I don't think
that's a big deal you're going to lose a
lot of people from both sides but that's
why I'm I'm saying that is a needle and
if you show me that needle and that's
got oral sex and it's going to any grade
in high school I agree with you that
needle should be taken out of the
haystack okay but would you would you
fight that fight would you get behind
that fight yeah if you said if you you
show me this exact book I'll send you
all the books right and so if you show
me about like but at the same time pat
let me ask you this yeah now they're
taking out a tons of books that don't
have anything to do with anything that
aren't talking about sex but they're
talking about gay people existing well
they took out one book that was two
penguins that aren't even gay and
they're not even human they're goddamn
penguins that took care of a baby and
they're like ah it looks a little gay
and they took it out I mean come on and
then you tell me you're not against gay
people Penguins I don't know which
penguin story yeah but I look at it but
you see what I'm doing Pat I'm finding a
needle you're finding a needle no no so
no no not a needle bro this is not a
needle that's one thing I don't
subscribe to penguinology or whatever
that magazine is well I'll look it up
I'll take a look to see what it is and
I'll give my own opinion on that that's
not where I'm going with this this is no
longer a needle bro this is a national
this is riots protesting happening it is
it actually is in many describing hatred
pad it is the point is you're right and
it started from the left no it's a
division started by the left nobody you
didn't have to put that magazine in
there Pat look I'm I'm doing a rebellion
against a portion of the left that goes
too far and and they and now that
portion thinks I'm a right winger they
thought I was going to come on here and
declare that I was a republican does it
sound like I'm a republican okay okay
and a whole bunch of people think I'm
establishing it does it sound like that
no it's not like a democratic capitalist
exactly okay so but but Pat so if you
say hey these folks are going too far
when they're saying that surgery should
be okay and by the way the real problem
in California was crime and that's why
people were leaving if you want to talk
about how people went too far the left
0.24 in crime we're having a real
conversation but in terms of I lgbtq
folks no look I have a a guy I ran into
at a business conference it lives down
in Miami yeah okay and he said my kid
and I took a picture we had it in the
we're gonna they asked for a yearbook
right yeah and uh and then we had the
pride flag in the back just
coincidentally because I I'm gay right
and we happen to have one in the back
they took it out of the yearbook because
you can't talk about gay people and
because the teachers are worried they're
going to get sued and they're going to
go get bankrupt right and so and there
was an and then she uh his daughter
wrote a story about how their their
summer vacation and what they did and in
it she mentioned that her dad was gay
because talking about his partner
they're like don't write that story
you're not allowed to write that story
Pat it's true it's too much brother Bill
Maher bill in high school how many kids
were gay when he went to school you're
not about the same age how many kids
were gay in high school be honest like
don't give I'm not telling you hey Joey
was gay I'm saying like that you know
you and I know about how many kids were
in high school that were out that were
out well you know it was terrible to
come out back then and maybe one maybe
two but me too right and then later on
they came out and like okay cool bro
it's totally fine but it wasn't like it
was in your face traditionalist point
eight percent our gate they don't give a
[__] about what you and I think but
they're point eight percent gay Boomers
is like two three percent then you go
now gen Z's 21 gay you cannot even Bill
Maher talked about this and Bill Maher's
not going to vote Republican I'm going
to tell you something no one else says
go ahead okay yeah so do you get divided
into these two camps which I don't think
are right so why are more people gay now
you know or coming out as gay
does culture matter yes it does and so
does the culture make them gay no what
it does is it gives them permission and
it turns out the 21 would have been gay
bisexual something along the Spectrum
and they didn't have permission are you
telling me that we had permission before
do you know how it was when we grew up
they did not have permission stop okay I
don't understand are finally coming out
no it's also okay so what religion oh
you were a Muslim what do you know
atheists you're an atheist yeah who
persuade you to become an atheist uh you
didn't do it independent I'll tell you
what persated me I read the Quran in the
Bible and then I became an atheist you
you read those books did any influence
of the Hitchens did any influence of
anybody else any other books nothing no
I just read the Quran on the Bible and I
was like these are obviously not correct
those are not me I'm gonna go be an
atheist that was your way okay how many
people you think become Christians
because somebody baptized them and
persuaded them almost all of them okay
same thing with gay it's a religion
being gay is a religion of course it is
so lgbtq has become a religion okay so I
got eight more minutes what I want to do
is I want to go into a couple a couple
other issues before we wrap up fair with
this one what I will tell you on the
mother side
why I like what direction you're going
with that I'll give you my feedback on
that anything to support
um
increasing the number of babies we're
having in America
in a in a climate where Mom and Dad are
existent I'm for that any entitlement
program that encourages mothers to have
babies without a father being in the
picture I am not for that entitlement
program there should be no incentives to
incentivize somebody to get 500 bucks a
month from the government to have more
kids if any of those types of programs I
don't support it I support your marriage
you have two kids guess what let's keep
recognizing people that are married with
two or three kids if this is us I'm not
going to go 83 and we say well 83 months
83 weeks at these different places we're
not trying to be those countries they're
trying to be us we're not competing with
those guys hey look what these guys I
don't care what the other guy's doing
like you know in my family my kids will
come and say you know Joey has a phone
at six years old I don't give a [__] I
don't give a kid at four years old got a
phone you ain't gonna give one of my
family so my standard isn't to try to be
Europe Europe is trying to be us and
they fail we have proven that the
American system is the best system in
the world based on many different
metrics we can talk about involvement in
wars and all that other stuff so set
that stuff aside that's the military
industrial complex but why are you here
as an immigrant why am I here white male
because it's the best system let me go
to the last part before we wrap up
because we haven't talked about this at
all
and we can maybe folks what we may do
the next time is maybe we'll do a live
uh event next time with me you and we'll
invite somebody would you ever do
something with Alex Jones or no
we've never been the same room with Alex
no no what if I moderators the three of
us are the guy's a lunatic what do I
what am I going to have a reasonable
conversation with him you like
entertainment I think it'll be I think
it'll be I would ever entertain a three
hour with them I went on a show about a
decade ago and I went all the way down
the rabbit hole and I I kept asking him
because she's okay Alex what happens
next what happens next so after all your
conspiracies and at the end he's like oh
the the people who control the world are
going to kill 90 of us let me be the
mediator would you do it if I did it
would you do it I look I I'm I'm willing
to do a lot of podcasts going forward
right and I'm willing to do a lot of
media would you do Alex I'd have to
think about it because he's a lunatic
can you do it think about it and let me
know because some of the others I say
you're a lunatic so to me I like talking
to both of you guys so for me I don't
have a problem talking to either one of
you guys what if I'm gonna but he's not
in the fact-based world like he's gonna
say I'm gonna say things that are based
on facts and he's gonna say that both
frogs are gay I mean totally get it but
but a part of it is entertainment a part
of it I think the audience would like to
see it and if you're better at argue
you're pretty good debater maybe you win
the argument and you're gonna
you'll think about it you'll let me know
if you're open to the idea or not maybe
in the next one we do we'll do live
audience 200 people in the Cigar Lounge
we'll do it at the other place but I
want to wrap it up with this I want to
wrap it up with this I knew two and a
half hours wasn't going to be by the way
just so you know we never start at 8 30.
we never do we start at 8 30 because I
know we needed more time with you and I
got a weekly 11 o'clock zoom on Tuesdays
which screws me up on Thursdays I don't
have one
um can you do me a favor play the two
clips uh because it is a current event
that we have to react to uh Tico can you
let the guys that I'm going to be late a
couple minutes here so Devin Archer okay
um with the stories that came out let me
just read the Devon Archer story okay
here we go let me just read the story
page four
we'll get a quick reaction on this
Archer says Joe Biden spoke with
Hunter's business partners 20 times
Hunter writings business partner Devin
Archer testified that Joe Biden had more
than 20 phone calls with Hunter's
business partners raising concerns about
the former vice president's involvement
in the sons overseas deals with raked in
millions from countries like China and
Romania Democrats argued that the phone
calls were innocent and did not involve
business matters representative Dan
Goldman stated that they were nicest I'd
even pronounce that niceties
such as the
weathertees such as the weather on the
contrary Republicans view Archer's
testimony as damning evidence of bidens
being in the actual business of
influence peddling representative
Marjorie Taylor green emphasized that
the 20 phone call conversations were
directly related to business deals Not
Mere casual conversations if you can
play this clip and I'll get your
reaction go for it
you're saying that the speakerphone
conversations they don't seem concerning
to you because there is no specifics
about business and it just seemed like
it was clear that it was clear that it
was as part of the daily conversations
that Hunter Biden had with his father
um and it was and and sounded like most
of the time uh
now President Biden didn't even know who
the people he was at dinner he was just
asked to say hello uh and he would you
know talk about the the way he described
it several times they asked over and
over and over he described what the
weather was how uh how what's going on
on your end he the the witness was very
very consistent that none of those
conversations ever had to do with any
business dealings or transactions they
were purely what he called casual
conversation
So you you're probably following this
close story what do you think is going
on here is anything going to happen Okay
so is Hunter Biden a crook generally
speaking yes okay so first of all he's
apparently a Ukrainian gas expert and
one of the best artists in the country
okay now now are people paying him
because his last name is Biden of course
of course of course you'd be a nut to
say that that's not the case right so
that's not the question because I don't
give a goddamn about Hunter Biden the
question is did Joe Biden do anything
wrong and so the five million dollar
thing totally made up they got no
evidence the guy comes in goes nope
there's no five million dollar payment
and that original uh document was
somebody saying second hand I heard
somebody else say it I don't even
believe it right so okay so that's not
true so then by the way when they got
his famous laptop and they finally
looked at it there's messages in there
we did the story on on Young Turks where
he says look don't promise that a dad
can do anything because he won't it's
actually exculpatory but right-wing
media ever talks about that part of the
laptop okay so in this case the 20 calls
Biden calls all of his kids and all of
his grandkids every day or something
like that and by the way I think he
overdoes it okay I got a kid from
Scranton I got it okay oh you're a
family man except he wasn't calling the
seventh grandchild anyways so is Hunter
Biden doing a Cheesy thing where I we're
in a business call hey look this is my
dad Joe Biden and they talk about the
weather and go see see I know Joe Biden
yeah yeah I yeah that's what he's doing
is it cheesy super cheesy potentially
illegal maybe right but is Joe Biden
helping him there's been zero evidence
that Joe Biden helped him in fact on the
laptop it says
pop won't help us right so don't promise
it the old speakerphone deal hey uh did
you see the text exchange between the
two Vinnie were you following this
closely well I'll just following listen
just watching this whole thing and I
hate to go back to if can you imagine if
Trump was doing this this is just
showing oh I can't yeah Justin but if
you think about it now we have bank
records text messages emails the hunter
Devon Archer who testified that the
brand the big guy and the chairman is is
his father yeah credible whistleblowers
I spent hours talking about extortion
trees and bribery everything right the
recorded phone call with Joe Biden and
poroshenko and that video that we saw
for years about him bragging firing
Victor shulkin and now we wonder why now
now you wonder why that impeachment uh
the impeached Trump about barisma that's
all Trump was saying investigate about
this what's happening right now no and
they impeached him for it guys look if
you had evidence against Joe Biden I I
look no hold on let me explain
if you had evidence I'd be thrilled I
think Joe Biden's gonna lose and I and I
and I think he's way too conservative I
think he lies all the time I'd rather
have him out okay that's my political
leaning but besides that I if you just
showed me evidence and I love the guy
I'd still say yes but look at all the
text messages and none of them do they
ever say Joe Biden is going to do this
they never say it because he never did
it if you bring the evidence of that
I'll switch in a second and then people
like oh are you turning Republican no I
just care about facts right now and so
by the way you said imagine if Trump did
it are you kidding me Trump leaves
office remember they let uh Muhammad bin
Salman chop up a guy right and then
Jared Kushner gets a two billion dollar
deal
two billion dollar deal okay and then
Trump gets millions of dollars from the
live golf tournament also from the
Saudis and we're not having that
conversation by the way the Democrats
suck at this if I was a Democrats I'd be
like you're doing a hearing on impeach
them twice they're great
50 60 times I mean it's like nonstop no
I don't I look I think they're super
soft and they only do it to Trump they
they love other Republicans they there
and they love establishment again
like Trump but if I was the Democrats
and you did a hunter Biden here I'd go
to the Senate and do a Jared Kushner uh
hearing I'd say where's the two billion
dollars sure how much money are you
gonna make from the two billion dollars
what did you do show me your track
record because Jared Kushner has a
terrible track record in business he one
of the worst real estate deals in
American history 666 Fifth Avenue he's a
total miserable failure in business show
me how you got that two billion dollars
from the Saudis let's have a
conversation about real problems in
America and by the way that doesn't
foreclose you having legitimate
questions about Hunter Biden Hunter
Biden definitely did all those stuff all
those things right and if you show me
evidence on Joe okay but right now you
don't have it you don't have it in fact
the comer and and Jim Jordan came out
and talked to Hannity right after the
hearings and Comer's like I mean we hope
we hope it could be something I mean
where there's smoke there's fire no dude
you created the smoke so there's plenty
of fire on Hunter Biden but there isn't
any on Joe yeah I mean look a couple
things that makes me think uh Again
Naturally skeptical I haven't seen
anything until you got something do it
same with or the election same with this
I watched the 2000 meals I'm like that's
interesting some of this stuff okay fine
but you got to go Kerry Lake Arizona I
followed that to see what she was going
to be doing uh and how it's going to be
if she sounds very convincing but again
you gotta win Court well you don't
understand they're not even letting us
do this
the the fact that he comes out and they
said they're trying to impeach me
because I have lowered inflation it's a
very weird thing to say right when you
say something stupid like that right and
then they try to pull a fast one where
one of the guys called acting like a
republican that's a shady dealing you're
doing well that's going to be more 100
than it is on Joe still not on Joe okay
fine then you're asking for immunity the
judge comes out and says no we're not
going to give you immunity what are you
doing here so there's way too many
things going on it's early to tell if
they do pull it off and something gets
shown that is linked to it this may this
may also be the fastest way for Newsome
and these other guys to get him by the
way I saw something weird yesterday I
saw an ad with Newsom asking for
campaign money what are you doing asking
for campaign money was an ad being ran
he's a warming up in the world that's
that's kind of what I'm thinking is
going on so maybe the establishment's
gonna come together to kind of eliminate
this guy this could be an easy way of
course to eliminate to um uh Joe anyways
uh book Justice is coming
um if you don't mind taking 30 seconds
tell me the audience about the book
we'll put the link below yeah so uh you
can get the book by the way you can
pre-order at tyt.com Justice and that'll
show you all the different ways to order
tyt.com Justice and so uh the book is
about a number of things progressives uh
are actually two-thirds of the country I
explain definitively why but the most
important parts are chapter four and
chapter five chapter four is about how
we lost the Democratic party to uh
lobbyists and corporate interest and it
shows exactly how it happened legally
and how it happened through the
lobbyists and all the influx of cash and
it has quotes about oh yeah we're not
going to represent business interests
and not you know not uh labor Etc and
chapter five is called a matrix and it's
going to drive someone the Democratic
side crazy because the Matrix is the
mainstream media and they will destroy
anything that is against corporate Rule
and so they're the least objective
people on Earth and they pretend that
the corporate position is the objective
position so check it out at tyt.com some
parts the Republicans will hate and
other parts they'll say Hey I'm I love
this so check it out when you get a
chance by the way you can also go to
tyt.com paid leave to sign the petition
on paid leave go to tyt Discord channel
to talk about it if you're right wing
left wing wherever you are so uh I want
people checking those out and look tyt
you can get anywhere right just type in
tyt on any platform anywhere on the
planet and you'll get us I was going to
see if you dedicated chapter five to
Andrew Tate The Matrix I know it sucks
that he calls it the Matrix too I know
but he's like he's got a totally Twisted
view of it no I don't agree with Andrew
awesome Jank thanks for coming on this
was great gang uh a couple things for
those links gonna be below go purchase
this book and read it for yourself if
you agree great if you don't go talk
about the fact that you don't agree with
them and tweet at them and pose a
question about whatever part of the book
and put a screenshot of the page you
disagree with and let him give his own
argument for the book but uh you know
when books like this come out whether
you agree or disagree with it the best
thing you can do is purchase read and uh
uh support or again and go after now
couple things Vault conference coming up
in four weeks with Tom Brady three-day
event down in Miami for those of you
guys that have registered fantastic
can't wait to see you guys for those who
haven't uh looking forward to seeing you
guys I think are we still running that
uh the the the kai that he's talking
about on the 50 is that is that what
they want to do today or they just want
to run an ad for the vault uh they just
want to run an ad afterwards run this uh
uh at gang we got podcast we don't have
podcast Wednesday we're out of town
tomorrow Thursday we're not doing
podcasts we're still out of time we get
back Thursday Friday but Friday I think
we got mayor Suarez here to discuss
where he's at okay take care everybody
bye-bye bye-bye
Patrick David here from the Italian and
pbd podcast look once a year we host a
conference called The Vault conference
it's our Super Bowl where 3 000
entrepreneurs CEOs executive sales
people from around the world come
together to spend three and a half days
together from August 30th to September
2nd at the Diplomat Resort in Miami to
learn how to scale their business how to
identify their next 5 10 15 moves who to
recruit next who to go raise their money
from how to raise Capital how to
properly skill culture retention higher
fire all of those things and much more
and we do that over a span of three and
a half days and the reason why it's a
very important season to attend a
conference like this the following
reason today there's three different
types of people they're scared they're
those that are content and the obsessed
they're scared they don't want to do
anything because they're worried about
what's going to happen in the economy
they're going to take a big hit the
content they're walking around saying
life is pretty okay I don't need to do
anything else and then there's the
obsessed because they see a massive
opportunity today so imagine spending
three and a half days with three
thousand obsessed people that want to
grow in a season like this imagine how
much you can run from just those
relationships and networks so on top of
the people that are going to be
attending at this event this probably
the best lineup we'll ever have at a
vault conference Tom Brady seven time
Champion I'll be interviewing him he'll
be at the Vault conference Mike Tyson
will gudara the gentleman who ran the
restaurant 11 Madison New York that went
from a regular restaurant to a one
Michelin star two Michelin star three
Michelin stars and eventually the number
one restaurant in the world he's gonna
talk about how they treat their
customers so look if you've not
registered yet this is my recommendation
to you I never went to conferences when
I was coming up by myself I always went
with a spouse with a business partner or
running mate because I only have a lens
on what I see every night afterwards we
would sit there and say what was your
biggest takeaway so get yourself your
spouse your partner your running mate
registered to come spend three and a
half days with us at the Diplomat Resort
in Miami from August 30th to September
2nd I will see you there